e
I was giving a speech and I'm a
politician so there you go all
right so we have today the New Hampshire
Housing Finance Authority and who's
on thought maybe the car froze up
yeah all right please introduce yourself
uh yes Mr chair thanks for having us I'm
Rob dpis I'm the executive director of
New Hampshire Housing and I'm joined by
my colleague Jack rudderman who works uh
with me on legislative and policy uh
stuff and we appreciate you having us
here I've done uh uh have some handouts
at your places and prepared to give sort
of a short overview of past
Appropriations from the general fund um
understand that's what we're here for is
that yeah yes I I I'd like to learn more
about your
organization um you know what you do and
uh what happens if things go wrong right
I mean who loses if if a loan doesn't
work or something like that yeah that's
a very uh insightful question because I
kind of get think it gets at the um
origin story of why New Hampshire
housing even exists and why there are
other Housing Finance agencies and other
states that have a similar sort of
corporate structure where we are created
by state law and in some cases run
programs that are government like but we
are not a state agency we're not state
employees and and crucially our debt is
not the state's debt um and so uh so
that
uh sorry sort of trying to think about
how to wrap that into my uh my robotic
pre-recorded Spiel that I was about to
uh give you um so so that that sort of
explains uh how we exist as an
organization uh just by way of further
introduction uh we are uh governed by a
board of directors that's appointed by
the governor and approved by the
executive Council the uh govern Governor
appoints the board chair every year um
and they approve the project financing
that we do and we Finance uh multif
family affordable rental housing
projects through a number of means and
that includes both sort of federal and
state resources and very often as you'll
see from these handouts a combination of
federal and state resources a lot of the
federal resources that are created in
the uh primarily actually the federal
tax code as opposed to sort of Hud
Appropriations are designed to not fund
the total cost of an affordable housing
project they're called sometimes the 30%
and the 70% tax credit which refers to
the amount of the project budget that
the federal credits will pay for and so
um we use money like the state
affordable housing trust fund to uh it's
called Gap financing in the sort of
parlan of the industry um to fund the
Gap and make these projects um
financially
feasible um the the handouts that are in
front of you include sort of a a glossy
thing that talks about the affordable
housing fund and has some pictures of
some of the projects that we financed
recently inside the that handout there's
some fact sheets um that that Jack and
some of our other colleagues put
together that detail past Appropriations
to the affordable housing fund um that
first fact sheet has the number of
projects and housing units uh completed
and under construction uh the next next
page is a list of projects financed in
The Last 5 Years and then less
significant in terms of the amount of
money appropriated but also very
important the the state has legislature
has chosen to put money into the uh lead
paint Hazard remediation fund which we
administer and work closely with DHHS on
this we also administer a federal HUD
Grant to help low and moderate income uh
homeowners and uh landlords who are who
are renting to
uh families in those income brackets uh
address lead Hazard uh particularly in
in homes where there's been a child who
has been exposed to lead poisoning um
and you can see from that fact sheet
that uh we've used that is actually over
the last six years that the state has
put $6 million into that fund I believe
that was the first appropriation ever in
2019 um and that we've we've helped to
clear over 500 units the state money
there has been really critical for um
you know this can be really expensive
work you know $50,000 or something to
clear a a single family home of lead
hazards and a lot of our housing stock
is pretty old um and there are families
that are above the um federal income
limits for the lead grant program uh but
there's still no way on Earth that
they're going to be able to come up with
$50,000 to uh completely remediate their
home and and eliminate the lead hazards
that have poisoned their child and so
the state the state funds have been
really critical and although it's not
General funds and so we didn't included
I should mention there was another
million dollars in arpa money that went
into that State uh lead Hazard
remediation
fund um if I could jump back to the AHF
for just a minute and and we're happy to
take questions or or discuss I mentioned
that the uh affordable housing trust
fund is used as Gap filler for projects
that are financed with tax exemp bonds
generally and low-income housing tax
credits both of which are federal
programs I think it's important to note
and you can sort of see it from the the
uh sort of uh highlight box on the first
on the front page of that glossy that
that generally results in leveraging of
you know something like 2:1 to 10:1 and
and averaging about 4:1 in terms of uh
Federal and private investment dollars
that uh pay for a Project's construction
when you spend $1 of affordable housing
fund
money and uh the state gets an
allocation of tax credits and bond uh
capacity from the federal government
each year uh per the tax code which is
divided between the business financing
Authority and New Hampshire Housing
Finance Authority by state law um those
are those are General resources that
would go unspent if we didn't have uh
the resource uh at the state level to
sort of make the projects pencil out and
so I think um it's been it's been a key
intervention mention to help with the
housing crisis that in these past few
budgets the state has elected to make
historic Appropriations to the
affordable housing fund these uh the
numbers that you see you know the $30
million in the past two banial
budgets in addition to the uh creation
of the annual set aside of $5 million
for the real estate transfer tax is uh
is not the norm historically the fund
was created in 1983 I think by state law
and for the first uh you know 35 years
of its existence received only uh you
know sort of occasional appropriations
of a million or2 million dollars and
then things really changed when I think
the housing crisis came into sharper
Focus for a lot of folks uh about five
years
ago um one other thing I would just note
about the uh the fund itself we don't
take admin off the fund uh we are
allowed by state law to take a
percentage of the interest that is
earned on the affordable housing fund
that is in the trust fund in other words
you know usually that's money that's
been uh we commit it pretty quickly to
projects as soon as it's in there but
sometimes it takes a while for them to
start construction and then draw the
money down and so um so I think that's
uh to be conest a a pretty good deal for
the state because we're not uh we're not
really paying for our staff or paying to
keep our lights on and we don't receive
any operating funds we don't put in a
budget request to sort of pay our um
overhead uh essentially we're we're
doing that with um administrative fees
that were pulling off the federal
programs or um or in some cases a small
spread that were taking on the loans uh
which is limited by by federal law um
but it's it's very little in terms of
money that we actually draw from the
administration of the affordable housing
fund the state lead fund is a little bit
different we draw up to 5% uh of the
appropriation for admin we haven't added
any positions it's just essentially to
help pay for the time of the staff who
are charged with the administration of
that program and that is a more labor
intensive program to administer it's one
thing to fund a you know $6 million uh
rental housing uh project where there's
a lot of professionals involved and it's
generally very well-run doing a whole
bunch of small 20
$30,000 uh lead Hazard abatement
programs where it's occupied where there
somebody living there and you got to
relocate them is is um it's messy work
you know as anybody can attest to
they've tried to uh have worked done in
their homes so um so that explains that
um but but one of the specific questions
we were asked to address was whether we
had added positions as a result of uh
these Appropriations the answer is no we
actually um without getting too much off
onto a tangent some of the uh changes to
our business model over the past couple
of years as a result of the change in
the interest rate environment have
caused us to reduce positions and so
we've had to do a lot of work on
efficiency and um and so we're a smaller
organization actually than we were uh a
year or two years ago um but but I would
say doing the same or more in terms of
output and uh and Housing
Finance um I think that touches on all
the high points I wanted to mention just
one other thing that I I never want to
sort of Let It Be unsaid with respect to
the uh housing that we are financing
because a lot of people have uh stigma
or perceptions about what affordable
housing is and a lot of this based on
sort of the legacy of public housing
which for a lot of different reasons uh
is is sort of an unfortunate Legacy much
of it was sort of neglected and some
cases very poorly managed um the other
sort of significant characteristic of
public housing was that folks paid um a
percentage of their uh income as opposed
to a fixed rent and you know that um if
you believe that income taxes discourage
work then well that certainly
discourages work because it's an effect
a very high marginal tax rate um that is
not generally true of the housing that
is financed with these tools TOS today
uh essentially it's we're providing
below Market Capital to for-profit and
nonprofit developers around the state in
exchange for their legal commitment to
serve people who are at these lower
moderate income levels and uh for rents
that they can afford which is calculated
as a third of their of the not of their
household income but of the median
income for people in that income band
and so you there is no disincentive to
maximize your income because your rent
doesn't go up um in in these projects
and I think that's an important uh
distinction uh okay so uh you don't have
fiscal year 25 is that not available
or uh so fiscal year 25 would be another
5 million I'm sorry if we missed that
okay and you get that five million
automatically from the real estate
transfer tax that's
correct and
um so the lead paint fund does that get
money from the feds regularly or is this
it's still living on this six million it
had from
2022 uh I don't know if you could say
it's regular because it's not a uh it's
not a sort of an appropriation that's
annually in the HUD budget or anything
like that the the way HUD does this and
there's been a lot of call for some
change as they will sort of periodically
and somewhat unpredictably issue an RFP
and then states can apply and so we we
just kind of hope that those come around
before we run out of money and so um we
got a new Grant last year for can't
exactly remember 7.75 million okay um so
so yes it is funded by the feds not on
sort of a a consistent schedule in the
way that like the stuff that's in the
tax code is funded um but but we use the
state and the um and the federal funds
together okay and one last thing so um
the affordable housing fund it's really
grants right more than loans or is it
both it's both and I think uh so
uh it's almost it is always a loan uh
but it's generally a loan that is uh at
0% interest with uh the principal fully
deferred for the 30 just usually a
30-year term and then uh payments are
only due if the project is generating
cash flow and if it is then
the owner gets to take half and half
goes back into the affordable housing
fund um we use loans instead of Grants
just because it provides us with a
mechanism an enforcement mechanism
basically if if they are not fulfilling
the obligations under the regulatory
agreements the commitments they made to
serve low and modern income people or
whatever uh then we could foreclose on
them and that's sort of an easier legal
path to getting them to comply than
suing them so how much loan payments do
you get annually
roughly
uh not a ton I it's probably and and
that's partly the result of the
relatively modest Appropriations that
were made over past years so I could get
you that answer I think it's um under a
million yeah it might be one or two
million okay and those just add to the
fund for more exactly they go straight
into the affordable housing
representative Ms has a question thank
you Mr chairman and thank thank you uh
for coming in I I think you and I had
some interactions when I was with one
Scot you nice to see you um I I just a
couple questions um so what is what is
the total amount of general fund
allocations that you receive is it is it
an is it an excess of the amount that
you're showing here are there other uh
monies that you're getting in the
general fund no from the general fund so
the total that you're getting from the
general fund in FY 24 was $33 million
uh yeah is that the sum of
the4 yes okay and then um you had
mentioned that you were a small
organization how small how many
positions do you have well smaller I
don't know I mean we've we're about 130
between 130 and 135 okay down from and
so the result of that uh you know I
uh we had some positions we were up to
about 145 uh a couple of those were
running covid programs those programs
ended and those positions went away but
as I said we've also had to find some
efficiencies and reduce our cost
structure in some ways just in order to
um uh remain healthy and and stable okay
and those are all none of those are
state employees that's right that's
right we're n we don't we're not state
employees at New Hampshire housing okay
last question so um so what are your
um it's always sort of a uh the total
revenues number is going to sound really
high because it includes the uh Project
based or the the uh Section 8 or housing
Choice voucher program that we
administer for all the areas of the
the uh
like $300 million range I apologize that
I know okay probably looks kind of
stupid that I'm not answering that more
readily a lot of that is grant money in
and grant money out and those are that
is helping like poor people to pay their
rent essentially right um like as a
administrative entity our administrative
budget I could tell you more sort of
yeah that's proba that's probably what
I'm more interested in okay that's like
uh $22 million okay thank you y
representative
Griffin yes thank you thank you for
taking my question
um what is the typical rental of these
General
occupancy um units and do you have any
control over that do you have a way of
uh keeping a cap on that we do and the
the cap is the you know the contract
that the owner developer makes when we
Finance the property says for the life
of the affordability restriction which
is like 30 to 99 years depending on
which program they use can't be less
than 30 years in the affordable housing
fund um they agree that they're going to
rent it to people at these certain
income levels which is generally 60 or
80% of area median income in some cases
it's lower like 50 or 30 and then the
rent has to be set at a rate that is uh
affordable meaning somebody at that
income level would not be paying more
than 30% of their income on rent so if
that's you know the deepest affordable
units at 30% of area median income
depending on you know the of the state
and uh certain other factors including
whether the landlords paying the
utilities might be uh6 or $700 um at the
upper end I think you know a unit at 80%
of Ami in Hillsboro OR Rockingham County
um jump in if you have a a quicker
recall of these numbers I don't um but I
think you know you might have an
affordable unit that's at 1,800 uh9
00 I I might not get that precisely
right but I think the point is that
sounds like Market rent to a lot of us
but if you look at what Market rent
actually is now in you know Southern New
Hampshire it's it's and the second part
of that question is um how do you how do
you control that how do you ensure that
the owners are doing that or do the
tenants do that yeah no we don't expect
the tenants to know all those rules and
and enforce them uh we have a compliance
and asset management team and they go
out and depending on the program they're
out at a property um e either every year
or every three years and I think we take
a lot of pride in that because it's not
only I mean they're checking files so
they'll they won't say in advance but
they'll say you know give me you know
these six units maybe it's a tenth of
the units or something and they'll make
sure that the residents they've rented
to were income qualified and they'll
make sure they're not charging them any
more rent than they're allowed to charge
and there are serious consequences if
they violate their investors could lose
tax credits there are serious Financial
viol uh uh um consequences for the
owners and managers we also make sure
that it's like professionally well-kept
and a nice place to live and that's you
know getting back to that sort of legacy
of public housing thing people who live
in affordable housing don't have always
have a ton of choices and so there is
not always the same incentive that there
is in market rate housing for the
landlord to keep it attractive and so we
we work together with them and generally
that's a very collegial thing to make
that these are places that people are
proud to call home thank representative
rang and then representative Ms thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
I have three questions one um regarding
the lead paint program you said the
grant it says Grant assistance up to
$177,000 per unit what's the median and
the average cost of remediation like how
much does that 177,000
cover when you average median and
average cost of remediation I don't have
those numbers off the top of my head we
can get them uh I think the uh
especially recently it would be pretty
close to that maximum um just because
construction cost and particularly uh
sort of the cost of labor for and this
is labor intensive work has has gone up
quite a bit so I think we've seen the
cost of our projects increase quite a
bit in the last you know four or five
years yeah I was just wondering how much
does that actually cover the 17,000 um
and then uh you mentioned that you got a
7.75 million doll grant for that program
did that come from the federal
government yes okay and then my last
question is
um this program responds to when a child
has been um diagnosed with lead
poisoning but is there any part of this
program that is preventative because
once a child tests positive they've
already gotten some brain damage it may
not be explicit for years but they
they've lost IQ points so is there any
opportunity for landlords to participate
in this program prior to a child being
diagnosed just if the if the paint does
test positive for lead yes there is
there is I mean it's um it's a higher
priority if there's already a child
who's if the unit is under order as we
say as a child is tested positive but if
there's a unit where there's uh test
positive uh for lead hazards and there
are children in the unit but they're not
poisoned yet that's that's absolutely an
eligible project I mean we want to do
those and and we would like to do more
of them it's just an even higher
priority if there is uh you know a child
who's exposed to those hazards now I
think what you know the the reason this
program probably exists and and I don't
think uh is because uh the alternative
very often is that folks lose their
housing and it's sort of a terrible
choice for a family to be faced with to
either continue to expose their child to
lead hazards or or move and they might
not be able to afford someplace else
okay thank you thank you actually I I
have one um one thing I wanted to add
representative run um the maximum for
the Federal grant program is 177,000 per
unit but it is typically coupled with
the state Loan program and you can get a
loan up to 100,000 per
unit right representative Ms then evil
then camell sorry couple just two more
questions um the the lead paint Hazard
uh remediation fund is there any all
general fund allocation for f 24 and
25 no uh we did get that $1 million in
arpa funds U okay but no uh nothing else
okay thank you yes pres bble thank you
Mr chair I've got I've I just got a
couple of questions
um could you talk a little bit about the
challenges that you face in deployment
of the funds for investment in
affordable housing I mean and and is the
money pretty much gone
or and I I might have a couple followups
on that I mean because we've invested a
lot of money in it and it's interesting
to hear how it's how it's working on the
in the field sure thank you for the
question I think it's working very well
I mean I think the and the list of
projects and properties that you see in
in the handouts will attest to the fact
that it's it's making a difference and
one thing we didn't include for you know
we didn't want to sort of make it too
busy of a chart but we didn't include
all the other funds that are leveraging
leveraged there but I think the number
of when you look at the efficiency of
that resource and the number of homes
that are being created all over the
state um it is working uh the money is
pretty much fully committed which is not
the same as saying it's all spent like I
said it sometimes takes time for these
projects to get uh sort of completely
underway and and maybe that gets to your
obstacles question um I should mention
there was another handout that I didn't
get we didn't get slipped into the
folder but you each have which is the uh
I think it's four projects that we can't
say with 100% certainty that um these
are the four that we would fund if there
was an additional appropriation to the
affordable housing fund but we just
wanted to give you an idea um these are
projects that are um I think fully
permitted uh you know they've done their
estimates they've done their engineering
and things like that and they have
applied for financing and and they were
we found them to be eligible but not you
know we couldn't fund them because we
don't have the resources right now um
obstacles certainly the local permitting
process is the most significant I think
any developer home builder would tell
you that the uncertainty and delays and
cost associated with the uh High degree
of variability and sort of um the
subjective nature of some of that uh of
how that those local permitting
processes are administered can be very
challenging um State Perman is an issue
too and it's encouraging to see that
there's a lot of momentum for reform in
that respect so that folks can get their
alteration of terrain permits which are
a typical requirement for larger project
projects and uh driveway permits more
quickly um and more generally I think
the the same headwinds that face kind of
all aspects of construction are are
certainly true for for affordable
housing as well labor costs are up
material costs are up um and uh and
contractors very busy I was I used to be
a general contractor worked for North
Branch here in conquered for uh you know
5 years during the sort of Great
Recession uh which doesn't say a lot for
my judgment but it was a a time when a
lot of contractors were leaving the
business and uh a lot of a lot of them
you know have either sort of retired or
or just like there hasn't been that next
generation of contractors so that's
another thing where there's a lot of
good momentum around you know building
the trades but it's we got a long way to
go
got a couple so one of the things that
I've been hearing about is that
municipalities are very willing to have
these housing projects come into their
um communities and actually permitting
isn't a huge problem the problem pure
and simple is uh available
infrastructure water sewer sometimes
there are traffic concerns and um you
know some community ities they just flat
out don't have the Municipal Water
Supplies uh have you run and my
understanding is that these housing
funds can't be used by municipalities
for infrastructure improvements to
support better
housing could you comment on my
prattling oh uh thank you for the
question it's not I not prattling at all
I think um it's a very good question and
it is something you hear a lot I would
say that there is um you know there
there is some truth to that I wouldn't
say it's the whole story we do have
where where permitting allows for it
there are projects that are um not on uh
water and sewer you know particularly
you know you'll see some 12 24 unit
we've got a I think it's a 72 unit uh
property in Hampton Falls that's on
community Wells it can be done and so
the idea that it's just sort of like you
know there's just nothing we can do
unfortunately until we have money for
water and sewer is certainly not um not
accurate but it's it's true that that
more water and sewer would facilitate
more construction of of every type it
certainly it is true that municipalities
uh municipalities or counties could
apply for affordable housing fund to
build affordable housing they couldn't
do it they couldn't do it to sort of put
in new sewer lines um but there is uh uh
our friends at business and economic
Affairs have the new program with
housing Champions uh and I think they
are just rolling out the first grant
opportunity for housing Champion
communities where they can apply for
money that's I think uh sort of
specifically intended for things like
infrastructure and I think that that
that marriage between the housing
Champions program and that grant program
is makes a ton of sense because if a
community is going to get money from the
state to put in sewer lines or uh you
know water
infrastructure it I think it it makes
sense from the state's perspective uh to
ensure that they're using that
investment to the to the greatest good
in terms of you know creating new homes
for the residents of New Hampshire you
wouldn't want to put $5 million into
somebody's Water and Sewer so they could
build you know 11 single family homes
there okay just one more well uh there's
the interesting situation in my area
where the uh Municipal Water Supply has
been unable to provide water and they've
discovered that the groundwater is
polluted and so they can't have
Community Wells either um from yeah it's
not great anyway um it just points out
the problem that you can fix many laws
but you can't fix some of those
structural issues um on the lead
remediation do you have any sense of how
much progress we're making on
remediating the lead challenges in the
Hampshire no I'm sorry I don't but I I
could ask around at the office and there
may be some policy folks who have a
better sense of sort of overall
household stock age of the inventory how
many we've done and where sort of where
we are at in our uh yeah that's a good
question all right you might be
interested in the bill I have in
resources later today that addresses
some of that maybe uh representative
cells thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking the question along the lines
of what representative eel asked um I
lead paint has been banned for decades
now so I'm wondering what what's the
Frequency that you guys run into
situations with the lead paint where you
actually find it and um do you actually
spend all of the funds every year and if
not do you can you accumulate the funds
or use them for other aspects of the
program well we certainly uh there's
there is still a lot of lead paint out
there and so while I don't have uh
numbers on there we you know we're not
going out looking for projects we are uh
getting referrals sometimes from DHHS
because they have a program and so if a
doctor's office you know identifies a
family where a child has been poisoned
you know they'll call up either us or
there's a few you know Sol County
Claremont and NASA and Manchester have
their own programs and so we'll work
together with them to make sure that we
can pull the money together to help uh
eliminate that Hazard um is all the
money spent every year is the question
and I think uh we don't get money every
year and so we're we try to sort of um I
mean we put it out to eligible projects
as quickly as we can but it's not it's
not like it's gone in a year um it it is
certainly only used for this purpose
like we would never take lead money that
the state has appropriated and use it
for any other purpose um other than
helping to eliminate lead hazards and
and as I said the 5% that were allowed
administration and so do you have a so
you roll it over and what would the
current balance
be uh you know that's a good question I
thought we had it in here I believe it's
around
$300,000 in state Le funds but that
might been before we got that million in
arpa so I can I can definitely follow up
with that
information yes thank you do you do you
have an annual report that has like a
balance sheet and an income
statement um we have audited financials
that I can share our annual report which
I can give you is not is more of like a
glossy type thing yeah yeah right but I
can I can share our audit Financial the
a yeah that' be good um have you had a
performance audit anytime recently
uh we have a financial audit which
includes certain aspects of sort of
federal perform Federal program uh
compliance and performance we have a lot
of different uh oversight and monitoring
reviews under those Federal programs um
so I guess the answer is uh yes not
necessarily for our whole organization
but for certain aspects of it yeah not
by the LBA no no okay good any other
questions representative run thank you
Mr
chair um following up on representative
canvas's um comment of the lead
remediation uh projects that you have
how many come from lead paint and how
how many come from lead fixtures or
piping it's almost all lead paint it is
because uh the state does report I
forget I think it's every two or three
years um the uh concentrations of lead
that's found in any schools private
public schools Child Care Centers and
there are spikes every year and um we
had one in miramac several years ago and
it turned out to be from fixtures in the
school and that kind of because the we
have Municipal Water that's tested for
lead so we knew it wasn't the water
coming in um and we knew it wasn't lead
paint so I that was just an idea I had
from his comment is that there was other
sources of lead than lead paint and I
wanted to see what your experience was
right and one other question on um your
list of uh projects under the completed
projects you have some that um and I'll
just take Bridge Street recovery
transitional housing um it the type is
called acquisition rehab so is it adding
eight units or rehabbing eight units and
making them
habitable you know that term acquired
rehab what is that Encompass acquisition
and Rehab uh it can mean a couple
different things one is it's existing
housing and it's occupied and it's being
rehabbed and so like for example on the
orange up above the conquered roal
Gardens is a great big uh existing
affordable housing project on the
heights here in conquer that's very it
was in terrible condition had been
needing some attention for a long long
time and so we worked to refinance it it
got sold and we're we're helping the
owner new owners to make it a lot better
for the people who live there uh the one
you mentioned in uh
was a
Bennington uh that was an old Motel
abandoned motel that they bought and um
and rehabbed it to be recovery housing
and so um in that case there weren't
people living there um so so it varies I
guess the answer y all right we'll let
representative eel have the last
question okay it's just actually a
really quick one so um other than
referrals by uh a doctor or whatever to
the lead remediation program how do
people find the program do they have to
go to your website or what's the West
best way of people finding that um they
can find it through our website but they
don't have to go there I mean we do try
to do a lot of Outreach and so uh you
know we'll do events with the Community
Action agencies will get Flyers into
their offices we want people to be aware
of lead hazards as uh you said before
their kids are exposed to those hazards
or before they're poisoned um and and
sometimes we'll set up a table at
uh Community event or something like
that and and our partners in like I said
nsha Claremont and Manchester are doing
those kinds of things as well uh trying
to educate people once they're educated
they can reach out to us by phone or by
um uh through the website to learn more
about the program and see if they're
eligible yeah when did they stop using
lead paint I'm just curious 1978 is when
it was banned and so you know probably
some people had some stock on hand but
yeah
okay well thank you very much gentlemen
I'll look forward to reading your audit
thank you Mr chair all right so we had
scheduled the business Finance Authority
they were unable to make it so I guess
they're going to be rescheduled at some
point um so we have a free 20 minutes I
just wanted to comment um as you
probably
noticed I'm perfectly okay with not
going followup Mr chairman yes you may
follow up because you know we see people
that are mostly agencies and you when
you have a question you typically have a
a line of questions so as long as you're
not obser abusing the privilege you know
you have a few questions that's fine you
don't have to ask me for a followup um
but I but I reserve the right if you're
if you're going on and on to interrupt
you and move on to somebody else you
know to give everybody a chance okay but
um that only applies in here not in the
full committee the full committee will
sign well I have a button here that can
turn off everybody else's thing so are
you going to be leaving at 10 o' for
your yes so I I personally will not be
here at 10: uh for the Dr so
representative camell will take over I
we have a different meeting um about
bigger bigger numbers I guess and then
um I believe believe I have a uh one of
my bills is having a hearing later so I
may miss a little bit of that too and I
assume you know this kind of stuff
everybody has these things
uh you'll miss the next two I'll
miss 11 I'm well no 11 I'll definitely
be back I should be back for that and I
I and culture my my afternoon um bill is
scheduled for 1:30 so
um maybe you just run the meeting and
I'll sit on the side or something okay
o00
e
here with it being 10:00 um we now going
to have a presentation from the New
Hampshire Department of Revenue
Administration uh welcome and could you
please introduce yourselves
[Applause]
pleas good morning Mr chair members of
the committee my name is Lindsay stepp
I'm the commissioner at the New
Hampshire dep Department of Revenue
Administration happy to be here this
morning to talk to you a little bit
about what we do at Dr
and what our budget looks like so you
should have a slide presentation in
front of
you flipping to page two just the
mission of the Department of Revenue our
mission is to fairly and efficiently
administer the tax laws of the State of
New Hampshire collecting the proper
amount of taxes due incurring the least
cost to taxpayers in a manner that
merits the highest degree of public
confidence in our integrity further we
provide prompt and constructive
assistance to the municipal units of
government in the manners of Budget
Finance and the appraisal of real
estate on page three just a brief
overview of our taxpayer interaction
policy so it is the policy of the
department to administer the tax laws of
the state in a manner that demonstrates
efficiency fairness and courtesy to
every
taxpayer on page four this is a
highlevel organizational chart you'll
see at the top myself the commissioner
an assistant commissioner and then
you'll see our various divisions I'll
talk about those in more detail as we
move through the next few slides below
each division is the key functions for
groups on page five we'll start with the
administration unit so this unit
performs the administrative functions
necessary to support the Dr that
includes the Commissioner's Office the
business office project management rims
management which is our technology
system which I'll talk about in a little
bit tax policy and legislative analysis
so prefering fiscal notes and testifying
before legislative committees our legal
Bureau our hearings Bureau which is uh
here's taxpayer appeals of our tax
notices internal audit and Human
Resources so really just your back
office functions of the
department moving on to page six we have
our audit vision and they do exactly
that they conduct audits of tax returns
of individuals Partnerships Estates
trusts corporations and other documents
that are filed with the Dr to ensure
compliance with our laws and rules also
within the audit division is our
Discovery and Nexus unit and those folks
research federal and state filings to
help identify non-filers who may have a
duty to file and pay New Hampshire taxes
they'll reach out to those folks and
help get them on the tax roles if they
need to do
so on page seven we have our collections
division so those folks will initiate
collections activity in pursuit of
delinquent tax returns and outstanding
payments this is only after all appeal
rights have passed and the amounts are
deemed to be due um they monitor monthly
filings of our meals and rooms tax
returns they issue wholesale tobacco
license as well as meals and rentals tax
licenses and they sell our tobacco
stamps
on slide eight our Municipal and
property division so these are the folks
that interact with our Municipal units
of government so we establish and
approve Municipal School County and
Village tax rates so we set all of the
tax rates across the state we provide
technical assistance and training in the
areas of Municipal finance and
budgeting we Monitor reappraisals and
work with tax
assessors we equalized locally assessed
values of municipalities to their full
value we appraise public utility and
railroad property for those taxes we
assist with the administration of the
Timber and gravel taxes also known as
Sticks and Stones those are taxes that
are collected at the local level but we
assist the municipalities with the
administration of those uh we have
Timber and gravel experts on
staff and then we provide support to um
two statutorily administrated attached
boards which is the assessing Standards
Board and the current use
board lastly in terms of Divisions at Dr
we have our taxpayer Services Division
and this is the division that really is
um responsible for all routine
interactions with taxpayers so if you
call into our call center um you will
reach our taxpayer services division
they also receive process and store all
of our tax documents and payments um
they manage our forms development and
they provide like I said general
assistance and then they also maintain
taxpayers accounts so if you're not
under audit and you're not in the
collections division your interactions
are going to be with our taxpayer
services
division lastly we have embedded
Personnel from the Department of
Information Technology and they help um
design develop and maintain our
technology systems to support everything
on slide 10 this is a snapshot of all of
the taxes that we administer so Dr is
responsible for administering about 2.9
billion in revenue on the left hand
column you will have the tax type in the
middle column you will have the current
tax rate and on the right hand column
you'll have the statute so if you ever
want to reference um how the various
taxes work this is an easy reference you
can go right to the
statute taxes that Dr does not collect
um include the insurance premium tax the
beer tax and the road toll or the gas
tax but other than that we collect most
of the
revenue on page 11 you can see a
breakdown of that 2.9 billion so the
majority of that Revenue comes in the
form of the business taxes the business
profits tax and the business Enterprise
tax um other um larger taxes include the
meals and rooms tax the tobacco tax and
tax on slide 12 this just shows Mr
chairman just a quick question sure yes
representative Ms um sorry I interrupt
you um NF QA NF QA is the nursing
facility quality assessment okay and
that is a a tax on nursing facilities um
we collect it and turn it over to a
dedicated fund that's administered um by
the Department of Health and Human
on slide 12 this is a piie that shows
all of the general and education trust
fund revenue and dr's statutory
responsibilities are in bold and so
you'll see that that equates to
76.7% of the general and education trust
fund um flows through the Department of
Revenue um other areas that we don't
collect um include uh Lottery and liquor
you'll hear from those departments um
and they're responsible for collecting
overseeing on slide 13 um I wanted to
give an overview of our Revenue
information management system this is
our backend technology system um Dr
received a
$3,160 th000 capital
appropriation um to replace our aging
Tims system or tax information
management system Tims um was
implemented in 1990 it was an homegrown
cobal system um so think black
background green flashing cursor um I
remember my first day at Dr I put my
hand on The Mouse and the person that
was training me was like oh you're not
going to need that uh a lot of function
keys a lot of tabbing no no need for a
mouse um it was um becoming obsolete and
limited in its functionality
um and we had concerns about the
reliability usefulness and security of
the system um so that was prompted us to
seek the capital appropriation to
upgrade to rims rims is used not only by
Dr staff but also by taxpayers and
practitioners it was implemented in
partnership with doit um and as I said
is a complete backend technology system
which is housing and consolidating all
of our taxpayer data so everything lives
within this
system fast Enterprises was selected
through an RFP process to implement the
system and support their commercial
off-the-shelf software called gen tax uh
gen tax is used in the majority of
States um it is a t a software specific
for tax
administration implementation consisted
of three phases each taking about a year
um and the initial contract also
included support and maintenance of the
system for 4 years after implementation
and the total cost for that contract
with fast was $
29,5
15,000 um on the last bullet here you'll
see that that 7-year contract it's very
hard to believe but that expires on 1231
2025 and so we expect to enter into one
of three optional three-year extensions
at the conclusion of this initial
contract so ongoing hardware and
software maintenance will need to
transition into our operating budget
because the capital budget has run
out on page 14 this is just for
reference these are the three rollouts
for rims um I would note that their
project was on time and on budget
despite uh a bit of a global pandemic
occurring um in the middle of those
rollouts but everything went very
smoothly and everything was delivered on
time and on
budget on page 15 this is a snapshot of
what's called Granite tax connect and
this is our online taxpayer portal um
something new that we have um with rims
the ability for taxpayers to take a lot
of various functions on their own
without having to interact uh directly
with the department they can make
payments payments they can file returns
they can uh register for a new
license um there's also links on here to
report tax fraud to submit an appeal
request and to look up a meals and
rentals tax license
um so there's quite a bit of
functionality that taxpayers and
practitioners and just the general
public have at their fingertips through
connect on slide 16 so there is revenue
uplift associated with the
implementation of rims or the
legislature anticipated that we would
generate Revenue through this new modern
system and so the capital budget of
$3,160 th000
includes $6 million of general fund
bonds and
24.16 um that of 24.16 million of bonds
that are going to be um paid for by the
revenue uplift so the principal and
interest on that 24.16 million will be
paid for by Revenue that's generated
from the system and so the way that we
do that is there um is a requirement
every year that we transfer up to $4
million of the revenue uplift that's
generated into a dedicated fund to pay
the principal and interest on those
bonds and we will make those payments
until um we've made a total of total
million on slide 17 we'll I'll show you
the history of the payments that we've
made so in fiscal year 2020 we were not
fully implemented yet we didn't transfer
anything into the revenue new uplift
account in fiscal year 2021 we
transferred 2.2 million and then in 22
23 and 24 we have reached that $4
million cap so year uh from
implementation to date we have
transferred 14.2 million so we have 25.8
million to go in order to get to that
total of 40 million so if we deposit $4
million a year we'll be making transfers
for seven more
years at the bottom of the page this
shows the revenue uplift that was
identified for fiscal year
2024 and so we did that through a
variety of ways um rims allows us to
send out reminder to pay letters so we
send out a tax notice and then in 30
days if you haven't paid we send you a
nice reminder we found that folks really
appreciate those reminders we're all
very busy we have a lot going on and the
reminder to pay typically generates a
payment prior to rims we would not reach
back out with a reminder we didn't have
an easy way to do that and so we would
send the tax notice and after the appeal
period laps you would be transferred to
collections and collections would
contact you so this friendly reminder
has generated revenue for us we're also
able to better use federal tax
information the IRS has pretty stringent
um rules and restrictions on security of
the information that they provide to the
states and our old um system Tims didn't
meet um all of the requirements and so
we weren't able to um fully utilize
federal tax information rims obviously
fully meets those requirements so we're
better able to use that information from
the
IRS and lastly um through rims we have
established automated payment plans so
if a taxpayer receives a tax notice and
they can't make that payment in one lump
sum they're able to go on to Granite tax
connect put in what they would like to
make for a payment plan and so far as it
meets um some general requirements that
we've set forward it's automatically
approved and initiated we don't even
need to review it um taxpayers can
schedule the payments to be made to us
and so it relieves staff time for us
automated represent I didn't know if you
were leaving Rim so
I maybe you said this when is the Bond
paid off for the
rims investment so we will make payments
into the dedicated account until we
reach $40 million the responsibility of
issuing the bonds is with Treasury and
so they provide us with the debt service
schedule and so until we have um made
all of the payments of that full Capital
appropriation we won't have the full
Debt Service so I don't have the exact
answer to that because the bonding
schedule are kind of controlled by
treasury just um so um as far as
entering into a new contract for rims so
I was just wondering if any of the
revenue uplift could be used to help
offset that cost but it sounds like it's
going to be used for the the way the
statute is currently the revenue uplift
is utilized um for The Debt
Service but at the bottom on on page 17
you can see that there're in fiscal year
for Revenue uplift from rims was almost
$14.5
million we had the C have the cap in
statute we're only 4 million can be
transferred I had a question so if uh
somebody has arranged a a payment
schedule what is the interest rate
that's being charged to them for the you
know late payments sure so the interest
rate is set in statute and it updates
every year um we are usually two
percentage points ahead of the IRS
interest rate at a certain period of
time so we're usually looking at the IRS
interest rate in September we add two
points and that becomes the rate for the
next calendar year thank
you representative mons thank you Mr
chair so maybe I missed something the
the the on page 17 the 14.4 million that
is the is that the the the revenue up
the total revenue uplift for fiscal year
24 correct cor and only 4 million of
that was used towards the bonds correct
so following up on representative Evil's
uh question so there's 10 million that's
available that could be used for
something else other like operating
costs correct right now that money is
just in the general fund um but yes
there was rims generated 10 million more
than was required for The Debt Service
transfer but that's just sitting in the
general fund for all general fund uses
um and and and um that 14 million is
that has that been a a stable number or
is that going up has that gone up over
time that has gone up over time um in a
few more slides we'll talk about this
again just to make sure we're thorough
but um for the three approximately three
years since
implementation we have generated a total
revenue uplift of $3 31.1 million so
essentially in 3 years the system has
effectively paid for itself um but that
14.4
million is the high actually I do have
this information with
me
um so 14.4 million was the total in
24 in fiscal year 23
2.3
4.8
5.4
million and then in fiscal year 21 it
was 2.2
million so it has been going up um every
year with the highest year being in
I'm sure jumping ahead but do you have a
sense of what it's going to cost for the
uh operating budget for the computer if
hold that question get we'll get there
and if I don't sufficiently cover it let
me
know okay on page
18 um just looking at the agency budget
uh the efficiency
budget so the majority um of dr's
Revenue Approximately 80% is general
fund
Revenue we have about 1.5 million of
Revenue or um spend from uh the
education trust fund and that's for the
low and moderate property tax relief
program that has been running somewhere
between
1.2 and 1.4 million over the past few
years and then the agency income that
you see this is a combination of two
things the first is the Rim's Debt
Service so The Debt Service payments are
showing in our agency
income and then also included in agency
income are flood control payments so
these are payments to
municipalities that were
impacted um by the damning of the
Connecticut and the marac rivers when
that happened the rivers flooded the
dams are to the South the rivers flooded
to the north and there were towns that
lost land to the now wider Rivers so
there is a marac river valley flood
Compact and a Connecticut River Valley
flood compact um where municipalities
receive reimbursement for the land taxes
that were lost from those Rivers uh the
damning of those rivers and so that is
income represent is Massachusetts pain
it's where yes so there's a a history of
um some inconsistent
participation um on the part of the
Commonwealth and we've worked with the
Department of Justice um numerous times
to reach settlements with the
Commonwealth um we do currently have a
settlement for back payments from um
Massachusetts and we are cautiously
optimistic that those payments will
continue into the future so we've talked
about flood control extensively in Prior
years
I don't think we need to talk about it
to the same extent this year and fingers
crossed that um the payments from the
Commonwealth
continue um flipping representative Ms
has a question sorry it's it's cold this
morning and I don't think my brain's
working right
um so agency income it the the it
includes you said Debt Service and flood
control payments those are payments how
is that become income or where's the
income coming from correct so from um
the for the flood control it's going to
be payments from Connecticut and
Massachusetts and also a transfer in for
the New Hampshire the amount that New
Hampshire's responsible for and then for
the agency
income that is going to be from the rims
um Revenue uplift dedicated
fund the 4 million a year that goes into
that fund will use a port portion of
that whatever was necessary to make The
Debt Service payments for that
year so both non general fund
non-education trust fund Revenue sources
so The Debt Service payments are hitting
your your account correct okay that was
a change that was made in the last
budget um in the 2425 budget previously
those payments were made by Treasury and
they didn't show in dr's budget but
there was a decision during the last
Dr but treasury needs to per we receive
the amounts that need to be paid from
treasury but they sit in the payments
budget okay moving on to page 19 so what
does the agency budget um look like so
our current funded position count is
reduced by 18
positions down to 135 full-time
classified and unclassified positions
and five part-time
positions um the unfunded positions
include nine tax Auditors five tax
examiners in our taxpayer services
division two administrators one paralal
and one utility
appraiser all of the positions that are
proposed to be unfunded are currently
vacant and our general fund operating
budget is 70% salary and benefits so we
are a department of people and not
things or
programs the agency budget request fully
operationalized the Department's Rim
system as I mentioned the capital
expenses will end on 12
3125 and it also funds a conversion of
rims to a cloud-based platform so we
currently have um on premise Hardware
that runs rims um that Hardware is at
end of life and we have made the
decision to hopefully move to a
cloud-based
platform um funding in the agency budget
includes um Rim support audit positions
um and assistance in the hearing Bureau
were included as prioritized
needs other reductions that we made to
our budget include outof State travel
training and
Equipment um we at the department did
work very hard on this agency budget we
really understand um the revenue picture
and we want to make sure that we budget
conservatively and accurately requesting
funds for needs and not
wants to more thoroughly answer
representative eel's question relative
to rims so the agency
budget
includes um software General software
maintenance which is $800,000 a
year it's going to include Hardware
maintenance of $750,000
a year and that's for the cloud-based
platform and then it also includes time
and materials for consultant
support So in our current budget for
fiscal years 24 and 25 we have time and
materials um budgeted for six
Consultants that is reduced down to four
in um fiscal years 26 and
27 um so we will have four Consultants
from the vendor budgeted for um in 26
and 27 the reason why we do um a time
and materials approach to that
consultant support is really to make
sure that we are getting exactly what
we're paying for the vendor offers kind
of tiered levels of
support um where the cost is is higher
um but I wasn't comfortable necessarily
signing on to the those tiered levels of
support CU I didn't know exactly what we
needed so we opted for the time and
materials we have been successful with
the six positions um and I'm comfortable
moving to four positions um going
forward in 26 and
27 so with all of that rims will be
fully operationalized in our operating
cease on page 20 um just a few updates
on our budget priorities things that we
wanted to achieve in fiscal years 24 and
25 so relative to rims we did upgrade to
the latest version which is called core
21 and that went Live this past October
it has um enhanced security it has a
modern coding language so it should be
um easier to recruit uh people to uh
service the the technology and increased
efficiency and ease of use for taxpayers
and
practitioners also we've been very
focused on the revenue uplift which I
covered um the 14.5 million in fiscal
year
2024 and then also in our current budget
um we were able to upgrade our existing
Fleet so we have fleet cars for a number
of reasons we have collectors that are
out on the road we have Auditors out of
the road out on the road and our
property appraisal folks in the
municipal and property division are
regularly out on the road um we
modernized our Fleet to include
all-wheel drive hybrid vehicles that
will decrease um gas cost going forward
and decrease maintenance costs going
into the next budget as well um so we
tried to make sure that we could um
effectively continue our Fleet and not
vehicles on page 21 just a few other
things um technology upgrades with arpa
funds so um core 21 for rims that was
paid through arpa funds that was a $3
million arpa
appropriation we also upgraded our
high-speed scanner that's used to
process tax returns um significant uh
faster throughput speed automatic
separation of documents so that really
reduces our upfront manual work and um
improved image quality so these scanners
can read right off the page um making it
much easier for data entry
purposes we also modernized our
Equalization web application um to
include functionality for dr's
assessment review and modernized
platform for our ratio study and
Equalization functionality so the
highspeed scanner was $400,000 from arpa
and the equalization web application
upgrade was also
$400,000 so those were the three areas
where we received arpa funds those are
all like I said upgrades to existing
technology um and we negotiated with all
of these vendors to ensure that there
would be no increase to support and
maintenance costs so these really were
one-time um spend with one-time
funds lastly in terms of budget
priorities customer service is always a
priority at Dr um in fiscal year 24 and
fiscal year 25 um if you call into our
call center you um can participate in a
little survey at the end of the call
that has you rate on a scale from 1 to
five the
professionalism and knowledge knowledge
of your caller and 99% of our surveys
rate a three or higher um also when we
upgraded the rims tool to the core 21
latest version there were a number of
impr improvements to Granite tax connect
that online portal for
taxpayers um and we've seen great usage
of GTC so we have over 48,000 GTC users
and that core 21 upgrades um allows for
the ability um to pay review and update
the payment plans that I mentioned
review power of attorney information
submit an appeal or dispute request
being able to do that electronically is
really um a great customer service
feature and then also submit requests
for um certificates of good standing and
similar on the last slide we had
received specific questions um from the
chair so um one question was relative to
new general fund Appropriations so Dr
has not received any new general fund
Appropriations in the last five years
for any new
programs in terms of new positions um no
new full-time positions have been
established over the past 5 years years
dr's headcount reached a high of
218 in fiscal year 2010 and
2011 um from fiscal year 2021 to the
current fiscal year 2025 our headcount
has reduced from 157 to
153 and then there was a question about
whether General funds were used to
replace previously received arpa funds
and the answer to that is no as I
mentioned our ARA funds were only used
to upgrade existing technology and we
negotiated with those vendors to ensure
that there would be no increased um
support or maintenance costs associated
with those upgrades so again onetime um
money for onetime spend no increase um
to the maintenance and support costs uh
representative Griffin you have a
question yeah with the um repeal of the
interest and dividends tax how is your
department dealing with that and is it
likely to lower the number of people
that you have great question so um in
the immediate term we are in the process
of sending out 990,000 letters to make
sure that interested Dividends taxpayers
are aware of the repeal to make sure
that they don't file fiscal year 2025
estimates um we have a banner on our web
page we did not produce any 2025 forms
um and we have internal processes in
place to make sure that we hopefully do
not deposit any money that is sent to us
um inaccurately so if we receive a check
that we believe is an interest in
dividends estimate for 2025 where the
tax has been repealed we will be sending
those back to
taxpayers in terms of how it will impact
the department it's hard to know at this
point
um some states organize their
Departments of Revenue by tax type right
so you'll have a sales tax department
you'll have an income tax department um
we are not organized in that way all of
our staff P essentially participate in
all tax types um the repeal of the
interest and dividends tax will not
fully impact us until after fiscal year
2025 so we will still receive interest
in dividends returns this spring on
April 15th and then there'll be some
audit and collection activity that will
occur until we fully wrap up the tax
I will say though that you will see in
the agency budget we've reduced our
headcount by 18 um and some of those
positions are in our taxpayer Services
Division and in our audit division while
they may not be directly tied to indd I
think we're able to kind of absorb um
the unfund of those positions because
there will be less documents and such
coming through the department so I don't
have an exact this many people work on
indd but I can say that I'm comfortable
with unfund those positions because
there will be a shift in in our work
thank
you I have a question on behalf of the
chair because he couldn't be here um he
stated that we uh we allowed for a few
auditor positions in the last session
that we had give you some additional
Auditors on the promise that they would
be pulling their weight on the business
tax collections how has that worked out
we um have proposed to unfund those
positions in the current budget we were
not able to successfully recruit for
them um so in in Prior budgets um
positions have been added particularly
multi-state auditor positions um there's
usually Revenue associated with those
positions because these are the folks
that audit the large multinational
corporations um they do very complex
work which makes them hard to find
so um we unfortunately just given the
current labor market um had not been
able to fill those positions um so they
are proposed to be unfunded um a number
of the vacant ones are proposed to be
unfunded in the current
budget and one additional thank you for
that answer uh an additional question
from the chair um what in your mind
would be the least efficient tax to
collect in terms of expenses per dollar
that we
receive uh and
and can it be improved
upon the answer to that was probably the
interest in dividends tax um there were
a large number of Z or low doll filers
for interest in dividends um we have
just as many interest in dividends
taxpayers roughly as we do business
taxpayers indd in fiscal year 2024
brought in about 185 million and
business taxes are over a
billion um um so I think interest
interest in dividends is probably um the
way I would answer that question of the
remaining taxes a lot of them are fairly
efficient um the three other larger ones
being the meals and rentals tax the
tobacco tax and the real estate transfer
tax those are collected in a more
efficient way so meals and rentals tax
is collected by the operator the
restaurant in for example you and I pay
the tax when we go but the collection is
centralized with the operators so that
definitely creates efficiency um with
respect to the tobacco tax again that's
a tax on the consumer but it's
pre-collected by the wholesalers so
again you have that efficiency not
having to tax each and every individual
purpose the tax is pre-collected by the
wholesalers and then the real estate
transfer tax that's collected at the
county level and then remitted to the
state so those sort sort of more
centralized collections I think lead to
um pretty good
efficiencies sen uh representative Ms
thank you Mr chair um I I've got a
couple questions so bear with me sure so
you know to I'm looking on page 11 um at
the at the taxes yeah railroad tax
$100,000 um is I me know when talking
about efficiency I mean is that does
that require a lot of effort is it worth
it it doesn't um there is part of one
FTE that administers the rail railroad
tax um the railroad tax and the utility
property tax those taxes the the value
is set by the
Dr um and then we essentially build the
railroad or build the utility property
based on the rate and statute and so
Railroad in particular is is less than
one FTE that's working on that okay and
then uh um you know a a broader question
um you know on page 22 you you kind of
talk about the um the you know the
evolution of your
headcount um I would imagine that the
mission of the department hasn't changed
significantly since fiscal year 2010
when you had 28
people um in fact you probably are doing
more than or being asked to the
legislature has asked you to do more
than you were asked to do back then and
your headcount now is you're proposing
is going to come down to
135 um I'd like to think that you know
that's all made you can you can do that
through you know all the wonderful
efficiencies that you've implemented I
but I guess my question is um you know
at 135 people do you have are do you
have the resources to fulfill the task
that the legislature has assigned to you
sure it will be a new normal um because
that will be the lowest headcount that
we will have um in a number of years I
like I said I went back
to 2008 um so that'll be the lowest
headcount we've had since 2008 um but I
think there are a number of efficiencies
that we have gained one rims has
generated um significant efficiencies
for us two we have the repeal of the IND
and so we'll have some ability to adjust
our time um and then the other reason
why I'm confident again these are all
vacant positions and they've been vacant
for some time because hiring um has just
been difficult in the current
environment with the unemployment rate
being so low um every year the
department well on a monthly basis we
track and every year we publish um a
balance scorecard and so we monitor you
know the weight times on our phones we
monitor how quickly we're processing
refunds we're monitoring how quickly it
takes us to complete an audit we
understand audits are stressful for
businesses and we don't want to drag out
a stressful event so we monitor all
these things we monitor how quickly we
set Municipal tax rates we typically
turn them around in 24 hours um we're
monitoring all of our statistics and
they are all reaching or exceeding our
goals so I can say confidently that
today today with these positions
vacant I'm able to meet the goals that
we've
set um I think the hard part about
unfund
positions
is that might be a
position
that if another position becomes vacant
if I have someone retire at some point
during the two years of the budget
I might with these efficiencies and life
changing without IND I might find that
that unfunded that that person that
retired that I might not need that
position anymore and I'd really like to
fund one of those unfunded Auditors
because maybe I do now have someone
that's
interested and so it would be helpful if
I had the flexibility during the budget
to be able to fill unfunded positions so
long as I didn't exceed obviously the
amount of of money that the legislature
had appropriated to us that I would
sleep a little bit better at night
knowing that our with our headcount
going down to 135 if I had it had that
bit of flexibility just because we are
kind of moved moving into a bit of
Uncharted Territory with what life looks
like after indd and so that I think to
long-winded way of answering your
question that would be something that
would um make me feel even more
confident that we could do it I'm
confident the way it is but if there was
that flexibility um within the budget
then that would really make me feel more
confident so so how would how would you
do that would you have you know let's
say you you'd have two just a number two
extra positions identified in the budget
with zero dollars associated with them
so my understanding but I would defer to
experts in this area um but there has
been language inserted into House Bill 2
for other departments in other budgets
that essentially says that the
department may fill unfunded positions
during the bium provided that the total
expenditure for such positions does not
exceed the amount appropriated for
Personnel Services so I think that is
where we would get the flexibility we
would still un fund the positions we
would go down to
135 but with this I could have the
flexibility that um if I stay within my
positions reprentative thank you have
you expressed that desire to the
governor's office so with any luck that
language will show up in their draft of
their version of hb2 I have okay great I
know they're all drinking from a fire
hose right now so um but that makes a
lot of sense so just um another question
maybe I glossed over it uh did you say
what you anticipate the rims um transfer
to the operating budget cost will be so
um the we will need an additional one
and a half million in fiscal years 26
and 27 to fully operationalize rims and
so that is the cost of going to the
cloud and the maintenance on the cloud I
have
absorbed about 800,000 of
that almost 900,000 of that by reducing
my time and materials for the
Consultants because I reduced that but
essentially what's going to be new in 26
27 which is the last amounts that will
need to be oper operationalized will be
about 1 and a half to 1.6 million in
each year and you've built that into
your budget request to the governor
correct it's not like it's an it's not
above and beyond it's in the agency
budget um that was submitted fully funds
rims so it's all in there great
representative Ms um thanks I I just
want to kind of do the the inverse of
what I was asking earlier about Mission
um are there are there any things in
statute right now that create a
requirement for you to have to do stuff
that um really doesn't make any sense
where where we you know what thing
things that we should you should quite
frankly take out of Statute because it's
really no
longer um necessary or um
appropriate nothing immediately comes to
mind I mean I'm I'm sure I could dig and
find something but um I've been in this
position um for seven years so I've seen
most of what we do um on a daily basis
or a yearly basis at this point and also
I like to think that the Dr works well
with legislators um when new laws are
passed you know we don't take a position
on legislation but we will be very
honest with folks whether it's something
we can administer or not or if we feel
like the administration of um a proposed
bill is more burdensome than it needs to
be and we like to work closely with
legislators um to make sure that it is
it's only what is needed and not not
anything else so there's not anything
that is coming to mind regularly that
I'm like ah I wish we could not do this
um I guess I guess the the kind of thing
I was thinking of is you know is there
some some Legacy annual report that has
to get produced that nobody reads I like
to think people read our annual
reports we have a nice page on our
website um no we're not overly report
burdened we do have some obligations to
notify the legislature of things um
throughout the year but it's not it's
not a burden I don't believe and it's I
find it helpful because then I'm made
aware of it when I go to sign that
letter um so no I I don't think
so are there any other other questions I
representative evil I I'm looking for a
little education on swep so
um you were talking about the efficiency
of collections so anyway you can tell me
about how they're collected I know some
keep others don't and I'm curious about
the rate because I don't recall it and
I'm curious about about the um program
that you mentioned for folks to not have
to pay it based on their income sure so
um the Statewide education property tax
is set in statute at
million um it was lowered a couple years
ago briefly to 263 but it is back to 363
million and the Dr is responsible for
notifying the municip alties each M
municipality how much of that 363
million they need to collect and so that
amount is included when we set the tax
rates the amount that a municipality
collects from swept is retained locally
so it is essentially state revenue
you'll see it on the revenue
plan um but it is collected and retained
locally
what was the other part of your
question oh the low and moderate
property tax relief right so if you meet
certain criteria in terms of the value
of your home and your assets the amount
of money that you make you can request
um essentially a rebate of a portion of
the swept tax that you paid and so that
kicks off in the beginning of May of
every every year and um we work with
like
AARP we work with the cities in towns to
make sure that we get um publicity out
about the program we also always offer
that folks can come to the Dr and will
assist them with filling out that rebate
um so that's a yearly program and like I
said we've been sending back um to
Residents or Property Owners somewhere
between a million and a million and a
half dollars in total um over the past
few years is is that uh rebate um
application available online yep it's
available online um through granite tax
connect and they can check the status of
it as it moves through the process and
is it fairly easy to fill out for people
it's fairly easy and if folks like I
said have any difficulty they're more
than welcome to call us or come in and
we'll help them um get through it thank
you are there any other
questions well with that I'd like to
thank you very much for a great
presentation
and we'll adj this presentation at this
you we have a 10 minutes to relax and
then we have another group coming in at
11: representative
camls yes um I believe Bea is going to
be a little bit late I believe they're
going to be here at
11:15 okay thank you so we'll have about
25 minutes to stretch your
legs
e
do I have to open the hearing and close
it and recess it until they're here
I guess you
could all right we're we're going to be
on
e
all right we'll call it 11:15 and
welcome the Department of Business and
yourself good morning Kathy Frederickson
Director of Finance with the Department
of Business and economic Affairs
commissioner Caswell sends his apologies
he expects to be late he's with um he's
at the commissioner's meeting at
Bridge's house right now and he plans on
arriving uh thank you for this
opportunity to present our uh 2627
budget to you I've pref we've prepared
the um presentation that's been handed
out to all of you I'd like to start the
presentation on page three where we've
provided an agency overview to uh for
you to glance at we start with talking
about Bea's core functions we are an
agency of people and programs and this
talks about our overall um functions
business recruitment business support
Workforce Development we have an
international trade division we are
heavy into promoting travel and tourism
within the state of New Hampshire uh we
also manage the welcome centers that
hopefully you've had the opportunity to
visit on our highways we have state
Planning and Zoning Workforce housing is
a big area we uh focus on as well we've
been instrumental in the Broadband
expansion program in the state of New
Hampshire and we also have an outdoor
recreation office um we are a young
agency within the state we were
established in 2017 under RSA 120 and we
C we currently consist of two divisions
offices and many
departments as I said we um our
divisions are Economic Development and
travel and tourism our lead office is
planning within this budget cycle we are
looking to formalize in an RSA the
planning um office into a division as
well and under that division which I'll
go into a little bit further detail in
another page we are looking to have some
of our other key departments housed
underneath that division in our
accounting structure our mission is very
simply stated is to Steward New
Hampshire's economy and quality of life
our vision is an economy that provides
Prosperity balanced with New Hampshire's
Grandeur on page four is our current
organizational structure as it exists in
our budget like I said we have two um
divisions currently and we have multiple
offices on page five we detail our plan
that we have spent a lot of time uh and
thought and we it is a progressive plan
in developing this division of planning
and community development as I said in
the current structure it is in the
current rsas it is the office of
planning but we are looking to make it
the division of planning and Community
Development formally in this budget
cycle and in as we do that it will
Encompass housing as well as Broadband
under that these are areas that under
the um current structure there within
economic development but honestly they
really belong under planning and zoning
and the instead of working cross um
divisions and departments they will all
be under one Division and work much more
efficiently and collaboratively within
our
agency on starting on page six we
started in our presentation to start
talking a little bit Miss Frederickson
let me just as long as we're on page
five it'll be useful to have this more
like an or chart with um number of
Personnel in each of these boxes right
so we can certainly provide that we are
like I said we are an agency of people
and programs we have 78 staff members uh
78 positions in the budget four are
unclassified and 74 are classified
positions I've also looked at the
percentage um 71% of those positions are
generally funded the remainder fall
under Turnpike and other great thank you
very much you're welcome keep going
thank you representative M could I ask a
question and absolutely do you mind if
we ask questions no problem thank you
yeah why don't we wait till
of it is done
okay okay um so when we developed this
presentation we kind of structured a
little bit to talk about the different
activity centers in the budget and then
go into the actual budget request itself
so we wanted to give kind of like an
overview of the different activities um
so what their key function areas are so
you can see um on page six we talk about
the office of the commissioner that's
really kind of where you know most of
our indirect activities exist that's
where our leadership is our business
office functions fall under there our HR
follows under there um and a lot of the
planning for the agency occurs in this
area and it's detailed in here this is
where our budget request is for the
commissioner's office and that office is
80 83% General funded 12% federal funds
um and then there's other funds the
general funded piece of the welcome
centers does fall under this C category
as well um and we listed the different
directors that fall into this area as
well if you go on to page seven this is
also um an additional extension of the
office of the commissioner but this is
the remainder of the welcome centers
that fall under the turnpike fund
because we do receive um Turnpike
funding for the welcome centers that are
system um I'm not sure if there's any
par we can if there are any questions on
that we can address those towards the
end um on page eight as I said we have
multiple offices as well it was
important to us to highlight that under
the commissioner's office we do have an
office of outdoor recreation this
particular office is very valuable and
helping out with different areas of um
bolstering the outdoor recreation
community this particular office is
federally funded but it is in our budget
so it's important to note to us there
are a lot of inititive Ives that are
very important to um also highlighting
and bringing in tourism into our
communities on page nine we have um
highlights of the Department of Economic
Development if actually to your point as
well we do notate on the top of each one
of these areas how many staff members
are in each of these um focus
areas so we we have key results within
these areas and I know commissioner
aswell wanted to when he came to talk in
more detail about
these um because the on page 10 there's
also highlights of the office of
Planning and
Development as I said because that's the
current uh way that planning and
development is in the rsas that's why
it's notated as Planning and Development
our future plan is again division of
planning and Community Development for
this area but as you can see there's you
know many um key accomplishments for
this particular area and the budget
requests are detailed here as well the
other division on page 11 is the
division of travel and tourism this
particular division is um dictated by
RSA which is mentioned at the bottom of
the page their budget is dictated by RSA
1211b and that's 3.15% of the meals and
um rental tax starting on page
11 is where um I start to Det detail out
the budget requests that we have put in
we were given a target of just over $17
million to meet we met with um Division
and department leaders within our agency
to put this budget together in a very um
methodical man manner to make sure that
we were looking at all efficiencies and
make sure that we were really putting
together a very thoughtful and
financially um prudent budget and we met
the target numbers that we were given we
do have some additional prioritized
needs in here we were very thoughtful in
putting those requests in understanding
that those are probably requests that
won't be met in this budget cycle
however they are areas of need that we
did want to notate in in our budget
request understanding that it's probably
not likely something that we will be
able to do in this cycle but it's was
something that we felt important enough
to put in this request one of the
positions that is in there is a position
uh in the office of planning and
development that will if if we are able
to do that it will be um 75% federally
funded and have a state
match so with that if you take a look at
our budget our request um our overall
budget 49% of our overall budget in the
FY 26 year the request is 4 9% generally
funded 46% federally funded just under
4% Turnpike and just under 1%
other like I said we we did everything
that we could to look at every
particular area and make sure that we
were um making the best decisions and
putting in this
request if you go to page 13 we've uh
broken it out to the different activity
areas so that you can actually see the
details of our request
um the office of the commissioner it it
would be uh for the efficiency budget in
FY 26 3.6 million for
and almost 3.7 million for FY
27 we had some different things that we
had to consider when we were looking at
this budget we had to make some budget
Corrections for example um we looked at
prior year we looked at fy2 24 spending
for comparison when we put I request for
example so you know we looked at need
anticipated future need prior
spending programs that are currently
going on programs that we might
anticipate when looking at all of this
and um what was in there so what's
detailed here for example is we had to
make a correction to like the S cap that
was um budgeted in here we a predecessor
incorrectly put it in at the amount
instead of just the non-general funds
amount so there's a correction for for
that in here for example so that's why
it's notated in here we uh there's a
variance in here because we had to we
moved a position uh into the office of
planning for the division um creation so
we we've very carefully looked at all of
these different areas when we were doing
this we were very methodical in what we
put in for requests
um although I will say oh there's
commissioner cwell now when you go to
page 14 we did even the same thing when
we looked at um the turnpike welcome
centers we we looked at you know what
was a spend that was a need or a want if
it was a want we
it we didn't put it in here because this
is this is a budget where we have we
have to look at what's only needed and
so so that's what the request is all
about in here even on the turnpike side
we flat budgeted on the turnpike side we
worked together with the turnpike um
people to come up with this number as
well and they were good with that number
if you look at page 15 um that is the
Department of Economic development's
number we did see an increase in
salaries in this department this is
Department of Economic Development is
our second highest um draw draw um draw
on
salaries so and because Bea has a
longevity in its staff so we do have
step increases and things like that
going on in here and so we had to
account for all of
that um but and then that we had to look
at in in deed in Department of Economic
Development for example they do have an
aging vehicle in there so we made shifts
within we looked at um like rep cars and
travel and was there something that we
could potentially sacrifice there for
one year so that we could get a vehicle
in the budget in order for them
to re um get the vehicle could they
sacrifice maybe one trip and do it you
know via a virtual meeting or something
like that so we've looked very closely
at all of this stuff um and on page 16
is the budget for office and Planning
Development this is an area that does
not fully um tap into the general funds
there are General funds as you can see
but we also receive federal funding in
this particular
program um there as I mentioned a little
while ago there is a request in the
prioritized needs for one flood plane
coordinator this particular program here
does have requirements on the federal
side because of the flood plane
management um so that request is in
there um currently we are satisfying
that through a 9t and we can continue
that if
necessary um we do there are changes as
I mentioned in um when we were talking
about the commissioner's budget there
are some increases within here because
of the um division that we're looking to
form we had to shift some money back and
forth so that you'll see some
adjustments in there there's also an
increase because we have um Staffing
included in here now for the housing
Champions program
if you go to page 17 we have the travel
and tourism budget this is the program
where I mentioned a short time ago this
is dictated by RSA that it's
3.15% of the meals and Rental tax
revenue this is a program that um we has
shown and there's a table provided it it
it has shown that for every dollar spent
the the most recent return on investment
is $17 to the meals and Rental tax
revenue so um that that's an important
program as well and I know commissioner
Caswell would like to speak more on the
different
programs on page 18 we were we were
given a request to provide additional
information so um I've only been at the
agency for a year and a half so this was
a fun exercise for me it gave me the
opportunity being a numbers nerd I guess
to do some more digging into um Bea in
the past I took a look at programs
established over the last 5 years and
and so here is that information that I
know was requested of us to find we um
in the past 5 years housing Champions
was established within our agency and we
were given $5.25 million for programs
and administration on that program State
invest NH was also established $10
million was given for that the Pulp and
Paper manufacturing program was
established we were given $1.5 million
which is fully obligated the welcome
centers um maybe doesn't quite fit into
that request
but in terms of the general fund I feel
like that was a new program because in
2019 that program went from Highway
funding to General funds uh it was my
understanding after doing some digging
that the highway fund could no longer
support the welcome centers and at the
time the general fund was able to
support it so it became a new program
for the general fund so that's noted
here and also the office of strategic
initiatives um was transferred over to
the office of Planning and
Development uh it's also while I was
doing my research I also came across two
uh programs within Bea that were no
longer and that was the office of um
wind and that moved over to the
Department of energy and the Bureau of
film and media was repealed and that
office
closed on page 19 we were also asked to
talk about positions and when I took a
look at that again that was also a very
interesting exercise for me I uh was
able to find that we this I knew because
I had come to the agency at this point
but three positions were established for
housing
Champions um there was also a position
established for the director of
intergovernmental Affairs I think most
of you know jeie who is here and that is
her position and at that time as I
started looking at this I could see that
a lot of the stuff was actually also
done very methodically which I can
appreciate in my position because for
example for the director of
intergovernmental Affairs there was
another position that was abolished when
that came in um we also as I was going
through everything I also found two
other positions that were abolished
rather than
retained when the offices were re um
repealed which I thought was actually a
very nice thing to do as well um and
those I listed those as well as
additional
information on page 20 uh we were also
asked to about continuation programs and
this was an opportunity to list um a lot
of the cares act and ARA programs that
we have managed very successful I think
uh we do have some of those programs
complete and then a lot of those
programs very nearly Complete because
I'm sure everybody's very familiar that
arpa has a lot of deadlines coming up an
obligation one that's passed and spend
that's going to be very soon um and so
the programs are listed here and looking
at all all of these I know it's very
important to find out you know what is
the
continuation um effect to the agency and
after looking at all of this stuff the
continuation effect that we really just
see in this is the impact in our
department of you know how are we going
to um support affordable housing
initiatives and what we saw was the our
housing champion and state invested each
program that that will be the continuing
effect that we see within our department
um one thing that
um was not mentioned but is something is
also a very big program for us is iig
money we do have iig I iig ja money that
is um very substantial in our department
as well we have $196 million that will
be continuing through
2032 so we are pretty busy for a small
agency we have a lot going on iig J yeah
the the infrastructure money is that
what you list here as broadband and
capital fund program it is not it is not
that what's listed there it that the
capital fund program money is arpa money
we also have um and here's where
Taylor's GNA come in because I mentioned
program thank you very much commissioner
sorry I was late everybody thanks job
Kathy thank you uh to your question
representative oh by the way Taylor
Caswell commissioner Department of
Business and economic Affairs uh you're
referring to the I a money that's under
What's called the B program so that was
a separate program to uh established by
Congress to to um accelerate Broadband
infrastructure
implementation uh we had used funds
under arpa which was a different pot of
money uh earlier on that's the 122 that
you see there and th those funds have
been pretty much expended at this point
the bead funds have not yet been fully
expanded and they have a much longer
Horizon but they came separate from arpa
E A yeah so uh
Broadband Equity accessibility and
development I think is the name of the
statute but it was part
of um a second pot of money that
Congress passed in
2021 specifically for infrastructure
enhancements and they called it at first
the and don't ask me to tell you what
the stands for the iig
ja which eventually became the
bipartisan infrastructure law and so
they've called it a couple of different
things but that is the source of the
bead funding sorry for the acronyms I
don't like them anymore than you do can
you give us at some later time um more
of an overview of what you're spending
on broadband and what's done and what is
yet to do kind of absolutely yeah
including dollar amounts great all right
let's go to representative muns for a
question first thank you Mr chairman and
thank you commissioner um and and um
Kathy um what what is the difference
between an office and a Division I mean
you know why make the change because it
looks from the organization chart that
the office of planning and development
and the proposed division of Planning
and Development would have the same
functional
breakout so this is a a a a management
uh based
decision um we have two
divisions well well two existing
divisions Economic Development travel
tourism
development uh I can't really speak to
the difference between office and
Division I think office is traditionally
seen in state government is smaller than
a division but uh I recall at some point
somebody said well they really isn't
anything called an office in state law
so um but everybody uses it so I'm not
trying to make an excuse but the the the
the the the management decision we made
to to establish the division of planning
and Community Development was to not
just have the office of planning and
development but to add the affordable
housing work that we've been doing and
the Broadband work and those are three
areas where we have a significant
Interac action with municipalities
directly so with planning zoning
broadband and Housing Development
because a lot of the invest inh funds
were focused on Municipal support so we
put that was one reason why they went
there the other reason was because as
we've been talking about the housing
fund and the Broadband
funding the the vast majority of the of
the funding that we use for those
programs is federal in nature and it's
significant
and so we had previously had them being
managed within our division of Economic
Development which was already our
largest division so this was an ability
to take some common functions put them
in a new division so that it would be
easier for our staff to manage um
because you know uh all of the stuff
that DED does on top of having broadband
and in in invest became a difficult
thing to manage so we set it up this way
so that it'd be a little better for us
does the change in designation from
office to division does that do anything
to um
upgrade
the the position that's managing it does
it change the salary structure so we re
we took a position that had been uh uh
in a different area and reclassified it
to become the director of that position
a director of that Division I should say
so uh and we we held a um you know a u a
full process um and had interviews and
that individual that's in that director
position now um was selected for for the
job to manage all three of those areas
planning housing and
Broadband the reclassification it the
reclassification was a lateral move it
was already the same the same level in
another area yeah so let me go to a
different thing um travel and tourism
visitor Services outdoor recreation and
welcome centers all those seem to be
related but they're in three different
high level groups here some are office
of commissioner office of I guess these
are two office of
commissioner groups and then travel and
tourism yeah so I can definitely speak
that's a great question the uh Bureau of
visitor Services is the welcome centers
so that that they're the same thing um
they when we first got were established
they were managed under travel and
tourism development um you got to
understand the distinction between the
operational function of running 12
welcome centers and all of the
components that go with that maintaining
the buildings maintaining the grounds
hiring and managing a significant staff
of part-time individuals among 12
different centers is a fundamentally
different set of management skills than
running a marketing and promotional
program so um I made the decision early
on to put BV the Bureau of visitor
services and the Welcome Center
management under my office um rather
than um expect someone I am hiring to
run a marketing program to know how to
do you know how to manage that type of
function so that's the reason for that
separation as for the off outdoor
industry uh outdoor recreation the
reason why that is different is is
really exclusively policy and so bear
with me for just a moment but there are
about 20 states that have an office of
outdoor recreation and in most of those
States they are using that office as a
tourism add-on they're just saying look
we've got a great outdoor recreation
that's that's what they do um I didn't
want that we already had that we have
the division travel tourism So ba and
here in New Hampshire the office of
outdoor recreation is really aimed at
using outdoor recreation as a way to
attract business and to attract
Workforce and to retain Workforce so
it's very it's it's it's a different uh
uh purpose and in order to make sure
that that is managed and it comes out
that way at the other end of the the
state government pipe I wanted that to
be um report according to me and not
under the uh travel and tourism division
because I really see that as a
distinction that is important not just
because I don't like necessarily being
like other states but also because
that's how we use outdoor wck in New
Hampshire um we already know it's a
great tourism destination and we have a
division and that's their job right so
and there's more to tourism than outdoor
recreation so that's maybe a long-winded
answer as to why that's set up that way
so would that then be more like Economic
Development or it's a crossover for sure
yes okay thank you um rep representative
Cel thank you Mr chair uh could you
clarify something um the direct the
director had previously stated under the
orc chart that there are 78 staff
members there were 74 classified four
unclassified but when I add up the
numbers of the individual pages that
where you gave staff detail it adds up
to 105
78 versus 105 could you uh reconcile
that for me maybe some are unfilled is
it yeah you have 36 and 25 and 1 and 24
and 10 and
nine so what am I
Mission the I apologize the on the uh
Bureau of visitor service
that um that includes some
um I believe that's the one that's
yeah I'll double check those numbers
when we originally um fact gathered from
the different departments and then
reconciled against the actual position I
had to adjust those numbers that were
reported by the department heads because
they included um also part-time
positions and and uh 9s and all of that
but we're only focusing on budgeted
positions so I apologize I will double
check
that representative run thank you Mr
chair um as far as the welcome centers
and excuse me I I probably should know
this but you said we have 12 of them
where are they
located all right quiz time right so uh
Canterbury um uh s Sor right across from
the southbound version of the Canterbury
one out 93 um Littleton colbrook inil
Conway um Sutton Lebanon
and missing one other on 89 hooks it oh
well yeah hooks it hooks it North and
southbound um and then I'm missing one
on Springfield oh okay thank you pretty
good I'll try to remember let me see if
I should know them better quick but I
appreciate okay no that's okay um and
then uh a couple other questions some of
the welcome centers and I'm I'm thinking
of the one I pass on in hooks it um one
on North and southbound Lanes do do we
get revenue from the vendors who operate
there I think Common Man operates there
we do not that is a contract between do
and the managers of that position so of
that facil those two facilities um so
our role in hookit is to staff the desks
that are there we don't have the same
maintenance um function at the at hooks
at North and southbound that we do at
all the other welcome centers oh okay so
we're Staffing that desk when you first
walk in that's our people okay thank you
and then uh my final question is as far
as the Broadband initiatives um is that
being is that Broadband exp expansion
catalyzing any program initiatives to
attract businesses maybe remote workers
to the North Country uh or is it just
being really seen as okay we're going to
expand Broadband but are we using that
as a springboard absolutely I mean and
that is one of the best reasons why
having the Broadband program at baa
makes sense is because we are definitely
using that in all of our work to uh to
attract Workforce and businesses to New
Hampshire and now you have a lot of
communities in in rural New Hampshire
that have access to high-speed internet
did that did not before and that's a
fundamental disadvantage for those
communities when we're out talking to
businesses or Workforce saying trying to
you know say such and such a community
in Coos County has um you know an
industrial park but they have no access
to high-speed internet I mean forget it
no business is going to go there but now
they do so that is opened up uh our
ability to to include those facilities
when we talk to businesses and to
Workforce for sure
okay thank you
MH I'm could you find out for me how
many um work hours you have in welcome
centers weekly maybe and also how many
GSA hours you have weekly roughly yes uh
we can get that and it's a fluctuating
number you for sure because that that
staff comes and goes and as seasonal
probably in some cases in some cases yes
yeah so maybe like an average yeah
annual average or something like that
thank you representative e would you be
interested also in like foot counts too
maybe so you can see sure because that
helps that helps me when I see you take
um you take tick marks like a GSA does
or do I take tick marks I mean you know
so a GSA every time they talk to
somebody they make a they have a sheet
where they record I'm not I don't I
don't know that for for sure well they
keep track count we have counters in the
buildings yeah great all right thank you
representative evil well first of all
iig ja is infrastructure investment and
jobs act thank you ma'am I looked it up
um it's something worth noting I think
anyway um could you give us a overview
on arpa the upt uptake are we meeting
deadlines Etc so I'll move from ba
Taylor to gopher Taylor for that answer
um so so those of you that know I have
also for the past four years been
managing the governor's office for
emergency relief and recovery so all the
covid funds that flew came through the
state under car's act in arpa as I know
some of the members here are also on
fiscal committee and have heard me talk
about that for a couple of years now um
so as you as you probably know December
31st 2024 was the obligation deadline so
what that means under Federal parlance
is that by that time we had to have all
funds under contract so through Council
you know as far as New Hampshire goes um
that total under arpa that we had
allocated under What's called the state
and local fiscal Recovery Fund was
Million um when we got to that deadline
of December 31st we had fully allocated
all but about $2.8 million of that
amount um and what we had done was set
up what we refer to as a waterfall
account so um Council had approved a
contract that allowed us to effectively
take any money that was left over and
say rather than put that at risk of
going back to the federal government we
put it into the uh the affordable
housing trust fund at New Hampshire
housing um so that's where that final
$2.8 million went um but all those funds
over the last couple of years um uh are
fully under contract uh and and again I
would is is again I've said uh many
times the the the sort of prime
directive we used when when allocating
those funds and working with Council and
fiscal committee was in one-time
investment so things like housing things
like uh Broadband or uh you know the new
fish hatchery that's being built and
things like that were areas that we
really heavily focused on now not to say
that was a 100% there were obviously
covid costs that had to be addressed
programmatically and supporting you know
different types of Health Facilities
nursing facilities assisted living that
kind of thing um but uh in terms of
deadlines now we are in the window
between obligation and expenditure so we
have until December 31st
2026 to fully expend all of those funds
that are currently under contract so
now so I wasn't going to ask this but it
just joged something in my mind so a lot
of the discussion of the budget um and
you know the decrease in revenues we've
talked a lot about Federal money going
away but what you just said is a lot of
the federal money had been used for
one-time expenditures for and I mean my
recollection was it was primarily a
focus on infrastructure type yes
Investments so it's not like the money
going away was already funding operating
right costs and and we were very
cognizant of the fact that we didn't
want to create any new ongoing
obligations on behalf of the state um
for programs that did not previously
exist I think we would definitely see um
probably within some of the nonprofit
organizations that do manage some
programs and maybe they use some of that
for those programs that they're going to
need to be able to adapt to that but
they went into that with their eyes wide
open to the fact that this was not going
to be funds that that were going to be
continued so that was very clear I'm not
sure we got it in the contracts per se
but in all of our interactions with
those organizations it was made very
clear that you know you're going to have
to figure out what to do when we get to
the end of these funds thanks I think
that's a really important Point um so my
only other question is could you just
talk a little bit about your Fe feeling
on the um efficacy of the and and how
it's functioning on the invest New
Hampshire and housing Champion programs
the Housing Programs so the the the
federal funding that we used was um the
one almost hund million that was
basically split into two buckets of
funds one was for um what I call like
trying to get ongoing projects for
multifam rental units around the state
of all sizes online line as quick as we
could get them so we were basically Gap
funding um um a bunch of pro I think it
was around 30 Pro projects with those
funds and that those have almost
exclusively all been completed um the
other funding was used to help um
municipalities work through the process
of U establishing or considering
affordable housing through programs like
our demolition uh program that was used
to help um you know open up space that
on properties that have just fallen into
disrepair um uh or um helping maybe like
an Old Mill building get cleared out so
that that could be converted into
housing um that program was was very
successful and has now completed uh we
had a per unit program where for for um
for municipalities that permitted
affordable housing within a 60-day
window uh they became eligible for a
$10,000 per unit grant for them to use
effectively however they wanted so some
towns maybe put it into a rainy day fund
some towns put it into uh the project
itself you they turned it back in and
sort of lowered the cost even more um
and then that program was again very
successful um and then uh um and then
our housing opportunities program which
gave grants to municipalities that were
interested in EXP exploring if we were
going to do affordable housing how would
we do that um kind of on their terms
there was never any like you have to do
these three things so and then the
legislature uh two years ago passed the
housing Champions program which became
kind of an evolution of the second half
you know the work with our
municipalities so this is an opportunity
for communities uh to effectively raise
their hand and say you know we're going
to be part of this and to in order to
achieve this we're going to demonstrate
that we're using all uh eligible State
programs like 79e or different tax
credit programs uh that we have planning
staff that has and planning members that
uh are willing to get to have some
training and what how zoning and
planning affects their community and how
um you know affordable housing how
that's financed and how a community can
become part of that equation um so we
just had an announcement I think right
before Christmas where we announced the
first 18 communities that achieved that
housing Champions designation from all
over the state and as a result those
those communities are now eligible for
$5 million pot of funding for
infrastructure um funding uh through an
application process that we just barely
launched I think last week so um that's
how housing Champions Works um we're
going to have another round in the
spring for for uh additional communities
to uh apply for the
designation um and then we'll sort of
see how the the budget goes along and
whether there'll be resources that'll be
tied to that on the back end because I'm
pretty sure anyone who does affordable
housing development around here knows
that $5 million isn't G to last that
long in this environment so under
housing Champions you can use the funds
for infrastructure improvements yes oh
great because that's a challenge for a
lot of them um have you included more
funding for these programs in your
budget requests not in the budget
requests but I'm whereare there are
bills in the legislature to to look at
that thank you so um Miss Frederickson I
think quoted this um idea that that
department of travel and tourism
spending has a 17 to1 return on
investment I assume that comes from some
kind of academic study yes could I get a
copy absolutely I'd be happy to send it
to you thank you and do you do any kind
of annual report that has um an income
statement and a and a balance sheet for
your various
programs just for travel tourism or for
the Department for the whole department
yeah we we filed a report I wrong about
do oh I'll get you one okay and um great
so I have a I have I asked um LBA for um
comparison of fiscal year 2019 and
fiscal year
2025 so roughly avoiding covid but kind
of where were we then and now and your
department um alog together is uh using
fiscal year 2025 is 53% more General
funds than it was in 2019 so 2019 was
11.8 million to today it's 18 million
and that's quite a bit higher than than
the Statewide average which is more like
33% and so is that mostly the welcome
centers moving from Highway funds to
General funds or is there other things
going on it would be that it would also
be the addition of the office of
Planning and Development so when if you
recall when a couple of years ago when
they established the department of
energy um they took what was previously
office of strategic initiatives which
many of us remember is the office of
State planning or the office of energy
and planning um and they dismantled that
some of it went to energy the planning
functions came to our department so that
happened after 20 after covid so I think
that was 2022 that occurred so that
would also probably explain that is that
Regional planning gets funded that way
or not in a very small way it's a small
amount of money I think it's about
$155,000 that goes to um goes to the
regional planning commissions so what is
it mostly then
staff I meant so the department of
planning what is oh so we have a staff
there we managed that for example the
federal uh flood plane program uh we uh
we Monitor and and work with
municipalities on all uh Municipal
planning and zoning regulations
uh and uh assist in projects that either
our department or other departments that
are that are doing we manage the uh the
cord which is a a group of agencies that
manage a surplus property um a couple of
the things but those are the main
functions I think of that of that office
thank all right representative Ms thank
you Mr chair and we're getting toward
the end um I want to just before I ask
the question I want to apologize to my
colleagues because I'm going to ask
questions that I've already asked of
another um Department um so bear with me
um the um the headcount that you
currently have and that you're
requesting in in um in
2025 um does that give you the all of
the resources that you need to
accomplish everything that the
legislature over the years is put in
um I would say that where that starts to
stretch is in the welcome centers you
know we are um required to uh manage the
12 welcome centers um with um mostly
part-time and some full-time staff um we
honestly struggle with um how we perform
maintenance at those facilities whether
that's done through a third party or
whether that's done um by our own staff
um that fluctuates based on staff
availability um other things like um you
know
um um the we have to use a sort of a
portable bathroom solution for hours
that the facilities are not open and
that depends on a third party to
maintain those
facilities um I would also say that this
is a staff um um that is well some
part-time some full-time staff um they
deal with a lot of stuff there's
homelessness that shows up uh in our
facilities um we've had a story of at
least one Center where a couple years
ago where um the septic came to get
pumped and the top foot was syringes of
people that are doing bad things in the
bathrooms um uh and so you know things
we also have training on things like
trafficking and Naran use and that kind
of thing and these are in a lot of cases
you know people that are retired that
are sitting in these
jobs um and so maintaining that that
staff can be difficult so it's really
more of that than anything else but I
think if you ask me are we meeting the
statutory requirements of my department
with our staff yes but that probably one
exception would be where we cut cut it
close and then um just kind of the flip
side of that are there are there things
in
statute that um really don't make sense
anymore um you know either you know
outdated um responsibilities or reports
that you know you have to generate that
quite frankly nobody looks
at I would say um so when this
department was established in
2017 and we brought over the two the two
P main divisions Economic Development
and travel touris ISM we went through
that exercise at that time um there were
something like 12 commissions that um
were being managed by dread previously
that we eliminated when we um
established Bea um in the seven years
I've been in this job I've never had
anyone call and say hey what happened to
that awesome commission we used to be on
so and they and they had all expired in
one form or another so um I think we
performed that and my goal has been to
manage a department that doesn't have
any of that going on so there might be
one or two instances that Kathy hasn't
mentioned to me but for the most part I
think we're pretty clean on that
front simil similarly are there
committees and commissions that you are
required to be on that maybe we
shouldn't because our speaker wants us
to get rid of as much of that kind of
stuff I could certainly give you a list
of those U representative I can't
remember them all off my head but yeah
there there are some obviously that are
really important but there are others
that I'm like why are we on that um and
I could please do I will do that and and
H for LBA do we have any performance
audit for this department that we could
look for yeah I can take a look and see
when's the last time if we've had one it
was uh before the last bium as I recall
but I'll take a look and I can email
that to the thank you all right what one
last one that represents Sweeny thank
you Mr chairman thank you commissioner
for being here circling back to the
welcome centers and it might be a DOT
question based off your answer to
representative rung but in the areas
where it makes sense have we thought
about inviting commercial Enterprise to
them where it might help with the
Welcome Center maintenance yes um we
have and there are challenges to that
because and don't I I don't want to
interpret dot policy but
the the welcome centers that are on the
interstate so like Canterbury and those
S Salem um they are under different set
of rules than those that are on
turnpikes so that's why we have the
really nice ones in hookit and the ones
in Salem OR in the North country are
sort of just like off the side of the
road kind of thing so Congress has
prohibited the ability to sell things
there to offset the cost or uh to have
um anyone other than State sort of
manage those so we've tried to wiggle
our way through those regulations and
we've talked with Chambers particularly
with the one in inil but the only way we
would be able to do that would be to
completely um um dispose of the property
and and let someone else have it not
that that hasn't also been discussed um
but the the Welcome Center issue is
certainly one um there's probably some
other Solutions out there there but
given the constraints that we have we
operate kind of consistently in in the
box that we're
in all right thank you for both for
coming and um we will be uh in recess
until uh
everybody
e
okay uh I see that it's a little bit
past 11:15 so I'd like to open up this
session for a presentation from the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources welcome and uh please
introduce yourselves great thank you so
much uh my name is Sarah Stewart and I
serve as the commissioner of the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources with me is Chris Marino who
heads up our office of administration
and behind me are our five division
directors um the dncr uh was established
in 2017 um it is a unique agency with a
broad mission one that serves the people
of New Hampshire in countless ways
where the agency responsible for New
Hampshire's iconic state parks our
forests and lands historical resources
State library and even the Arts our goal
across all of these areas is to protect
preserve and promote what makes New
Hampshire special from keeping our state
beautiful to supporting a high quality
of life for our residents and attracting
visitors from all over the globe our
work touches every corner of this state
and although we are a large agency only
17% of our funding comes from the
general fund approximately $1 million
each year for the next two fiscal
years the challenge we face and one we
Embrace is how to make every dollar of
this funding work as hard as possible
for New
Hampshire the dncr is responsible for
managing more than 220,000 Acres of
public land 870 buildings and an array
of critical infrastructure our team of
nearly a thousand employees maintains
everything from fire towers and dams to
septic systems and hundreds of miles of
roads and snowmobile trails which are
vital to New Hampshire's outdoor
recreation economy this is a substantial
portfolio and I am proud to say that our
team meets these responsibilities with
resourcefulness commitment and
efficiency one area where the dncr
shines is in our Revenue generation New
Hampshire state parks for instance has
become one of the most efficient Park
systems in the country through
Innovation and a commitment to
self-sufficiency we fully fund park
operations from the fees that we collect
we also then reinvest this Revenue in
other initiatives that benefit the state
from Federal grant Administration like
the land and water conservation fund and
other admin and business functions to
the preservation of unique Scenic
scientific historical recreational and
natural areas throughout the state this
model not only saves taxpayer dollars
but also enables us to maintain and
expand Services despite limited State
funding our division of forest and lands
is another example of resourcefulness
Timber harvesting and Nursery sales
generate vital Revenue that fund many of
our staff public programs and services
demand for seedlings remains robust
despite recent weather challenges which
is why we invested arpa money into a new
irrigation system and a large cooler to
ensure future Revenue
stability at the dncr we make the most
of what we receive from the general fund
by leveraging nearly 4 million of the $1
million we are seeking we will generate
Federal match dollars necessary to
maintain our budget's impact in the
cultural resources divisions we
strategically use the 4.2 million
allocated from the general fund to
maximize Federal matches with up to 80%
or 3.3 million going towards these
matches this helps us provide more grant
opportunities across New Hampshire
amplifying our reach even with limited
General funding the New Hampshire State
Library building holds close to 500,000
books Maps government documents and even
some rare and unusual Treasures these
items offer knowledge about New
Hampshire's history its people
government and culture and are
accessible to all New Hampshire
residents and guests the State library
leverages close to 1.5 million in
federal funds to provide Li Library
services to more than 2,000 visually and
physically disabled New Hampshire
residents and to facilitate resource
sharing between more than 230 libraries
from the largest to the smallest in the
state through an inter Library Loan
program that moves more than 160,000
items annually throughout the
state as we approach the 60th
anniversary of the state Council on the
Arts and the 90th anniversary of our
division of Parks and Recreation we
remain committed to preserving our
state's Legacy and ensuring these
resources Thrive for future
Generations I just read uh a bit of my
remarks that were submitted in November
which was our budget um submission uh
per Governor sununu at the time I've
included that copy in your folder and at
this time I thought I'd let my division
directors introduce themselves and give
you a snapshot of the programs that they
Wilson good afternoon everyone I'm Brian
Wilson director of division of Parks and
Recreation um within your handouts uh
that you have your packet there's a
couple um uh color Flyers uh for
reference um as the uh just to kind of
reiterate a few things that the
commissioner said uh the mission of the
depart uh division of Parks and
Recreation is to provide New Hampshire
citizens and guests without standing
recreational uh ex educational and uh
inspirational experiences through
responsible management and Cooperative
stewardship of the state's natural
Recreation and cultural resources uh we
often like to think we're in the
business of making magic happen uh and
on on the public
lands
um New Hampshire state parks is um one
of the most efficient Run Park systems
in the country according to the National
Association of State Park Park directors
we are only one of two states uh South
Carolina being the other state that is
entirely uh managed through their
operating fund dollar so no other
sources of funding uh to run the
operation and New Hampshire was the
first to do that uh and has continued to
do that um and we've been able to grow
and expand on that model as well too um
we are very Enterprise minded um some of
the numbers that uh that I have here to
to share with you are just kind of our
some of our statistics from
2024 um close to 3 million visitors that
we've captured as far as recorded
visitation at many of our lands uh that
that is only probably about half of the
visitors many of our places that are
unstaffed um uh where we're not uh doing
estimate counts or or head counts uh we
we don't uh account for that traffic as
well too uh but just to give a little uh
size of the scale of of visitation that
we have um we have many campgrounds
across the state
um over 1300 campsites um our occupancy
rate uh was
86% um over the course of the season so
very very popular most of our weekends
occupancy was in 99 uh 99% uh full um
and uh we we've been trying to do things
where we're taking primitive sites and
um upgrading them to more higher
experience a lot of the projects that we
were doing with the federal dollarss the
arpa funds were to to uh improve
infrastructure whether that's utilities
Power Water uh uh and and electric to a
lot of those uh
campgrounds um 36% of uh camping
occupancy is New Hampshire residents so
a lot of the F most of the folks that
are coming uh enjoying our campgrounds
are are traveling from out of state and
I'll speak to more of that a in a minute
um one of the things that we also do um
is a lot of programming as well too so
that's Environ Al and educational
programs we uh facilitate a lot of that
ourselves through our staff um and uh
through Partners as well too um like the
student Conservation Association uh runs
a discover the power of parks program
where we have um uh interactions with
thousands and thousands of kids and
families over the course of the Season
where the staff are embedded throughout
the park system to provide programming
uh we also work very closely with many
of our other partners like the SEO
Science Center in Ry at odan point or
the mount Washington weather Observatory
who's doing more scientific uh research
and and education that uh couldn't
happen in a in a different location than
than it does in the state
park um one of our other programs is a
special use permit program that U is uh
a permit program that happens anytime
somebody wants to do something that
falls outside of our regular Park
regulations we we've issued over 340
programs uh permits uh this last year
from things like the Hampton Beach
Seafood f Festival to to races to yoga
on the beach uh all kinds of programs
that generate uh Revenue both for the
park system but primarily for the the
the groups and the nonprofits and the
organizations uh for-profit or or
otherwise that uh want to use park space
um uh we operate 365 days a year uh many
places are 247 operation as well too
like Mount Washington state park is is
operated uh year round uh all day every
day um we have 84 full-time staff and
hire um over 800 seasonal staff every
year then and um our recruitment machine
is is um very large um in order to bring
in uh to to recruit retain and train uh
and get everybody up and working uh
often times that's just you know short
cyclical Seasons whether it's the
summertime for the park system or the
winter time at Canon
Mountain um we also administer several
different Grant programs and um the the
fees and revenues that come in through
the park system help uh fund the the
staff that administer these programs uh
some of them include the land and water
conservation fund which is funding
through the National Park Service that
goes both to State Park projects but
also to local municipalities uh through
a competitive Grant process and then our
Bureau of Trails um administers a few uh
different programs a gr and a program
for motorized snowmobile and ohrv uh
programs as well as a federal Recreation
uh Rec Trail program all combined in
2024 we issued over almost $1 million in
in grant funding externally to to the
agency um through that it's working with
uh that that was 207 different Community
groups organizations or municipalities
that received funding so we like to
think of ourselves as having you know a
niche or embedded in uh a part ship with
virtually every community in in across
the
state um outdoor recreation contributes
3.9 billion to the an economic impact in
New Hampshire we feel that we are the
destination that people are coming to
when when they're visiting uh New
Hampshire uh they're they're they're
coming to frankco not State Park they're
coming to Hampton Beach they're coming
to mount manad they're coming to Mount
Washington and all of our other little
spectacular places uh across the state
as well um one last just to to is uh
Frank on not State Park uh this year we
reported uh visitation from all 50
states in 68 different countries from
around the world um and that's just at
that at that one Park location so um
that's just some some of the highlights
I can get into some of our our funding
um if you like or yep yeah I'd like to
ask uh on those special events the 340
special events for uh industry
organizations what what do you typically
charge for the permits um it is it is
relatively small
uh okay sorry um so there there's a
there's a $100 administrative processing
fee for every application um and then we
have a a structure for event size that's
usually in just a few hundred range and
then if we start getting into larger
impacts like uh displacement of parking
or things like that like at at the Sea
Coast for instance where things like the
seafood festival will displace General
parking we will run uh you know we will
run metrics on that and make sure that
you know the state is being made whole
on that so generally almost all of those
are probably below
$2,500 that the state's receiving for
all those permits um and the the the
benefit though that the groups are
getting uh through whether it's a
fundraiser um like I think the uh
Penguin Plunge which is a special
Olympic uh event that happens at Hampton
Beach they rais close to a million
dollars um you know in their two-day
event uh so we you know the the parks
our venue to really unlock that
potential great thank you chairman uh
Maguire thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question um how much do you
interact with the Department of travel
and
tourism um we interact quite a bit um
with the the department of Bea really so
it's travel and tourism uh the uh
outdoor uh Recreation industry office as
well too um so there's many different uh
facets that we work on both in kind of
cross uh marketing uh strategies um we
work with them relative to uh campaigns
on like visitor use management um we
work with Fish and Game closely as well
on that so like the uh hike safe um
there's a campaign going on right now
called wildly responsible that Bea is
administering that we're at the table on
helping develop kind of campaign and
messaging uh relative to you know
responsible behavior safety and and
other things and you know the best
places to go to yeah and is the fact
that um you said you're 99% full in the
Parks is that an indication maybe you're
not charging enough um great question so
we did just recently in the last year so
raise our Campground rates um that
process goes through the the fiscal
committee for our for our fee approval
so we have been incrementally over the
last two years um going uh kind of piece
by piece through our fee package uh to
kind of review and and look at where we
have the ability to increase fees so we
did that we did do that for for camping
and we're we're seeing the results of
that um our dayuse visitation is another
area the next area where we're hoping to
um uh tackle it that is extraordinarily
complex uh for us so it will it will
likely be you know a year-long process
for us to because it goes all the way
down to what happens at the toll booth
when somebody's driving into the park
where you come from Resident or
non-resident considerations our point of
sale system
um and really all the whole back end
getting all that and then through a
fiscal fiscal process as well
eel I actually I was also going to ask
about um cross marketing with the Bea
but uh so your fee structure is
statutorily set or how does that um
statute allows for the commissioner to
propose fees uhu that are approved by
the fiscal committee so uh through our
self-funded model um we have the ability
to make recommendations which the the
the fiscal committee would either accept
or not um to sustain that to sustain
that model so over time we that's what
we've been we come back to the fiscal
committee periodically um as as needed
probably the best example of like the
most frequent is usually twice a year we
come to the fiscal committee to um
review and approve uh the fees for Canon
Mountain whether it's the day use um day
tickets and the season pass fees we we
we we break that up due to the kind of
the seasonality of when people are um
purchasing those things um so that
happens on a reoccurring basis um it's
been a long time since the the dayuse
fees have been adjusted um so we've been
able to have really great growth um
without having to go to the fees yet but
we are definitely reaching the point now
where where where it's time and we've
been working on that for for a couple
years now and if I could just add per
RSA um we are supposed to be in line
with the market sorry the sun is shining
right on us right now yeah thank you um
and and so you know with especially with
the the you know as a ski mountain um uh
we work closely with all the other ski
mountains to promote New Hampshire and
ski NH and um and so you know we don't
want to be out of line dramatically with
the other uh ski ski mountains because
want to see them being successful as
well um and so it's a thoughtful it's a
thoughtful approach but our you know
when this was deemed the the funding
mechanism it was clear in RSA that we
were supposed to be aware of of Market
considerations that's that's comforting
actually um and so I remember during
covid there was a lot of talk about the
very heavy use of our state parks and Ma
maintenance challenges um I realize
you're doing a great job within the self
funed model but how do you feel that
you're doing on maintenance of the parks
would
you prefer you had a little more money
to do and and I also as you know I came
from Public Works we heard a lot about
your Capital infrastructure yeah no well
thank you because that was one last
point I was hoping to make so thank you
for uh for for that question um while
the self-funded model Works uh has has
proven to work really well here in New
Hampshire that's really primarily
because we have some great Park
attractions to be able to really drive
the majority of that Revenue so that's
The Flume Gorge that's the Sea Coast um
those those are the places that help
support a lot of the smaller parks that
just are are not there intended to be a
main Revenue Source the Madison Boulder
you know there's nobody there collecting
fees to to to come look at you know a
big Glacier erratic Rock um but um where
the vulnerability I think lies is the
the states uh willingness to reinvest
into the park system so uh generally
historically over time the capital
Appropriations for state parks have been
pretty uh small I I I think um the
Redevelopment in Hampton Beach State
Park is is is the largest that has
happened in the in the
last 100 years probably um and I think
uh just you know one look at um the you
know the Ocean Boulevard down there and
all the Redevelopment that is happened
on the west side of the street that came
after the park put in the investment to
that I think speaks um volumes to what
the possibilities are that could happen
um we were fortunate enough to get uh
about $30 million from the the arpa
program to to put into park projects so
um we're we're doing a lot of great work
uh right now but the that doesn't go
very far um for instance we have a $4.5
million project that is replacing uh
five bathrooms at Puckaway State Park um
a bath house renovation or a new
bathroom building at a park is about a
million dollars um so uh when we get $2
million a year for a capital
appropriation or something that that
that that is struggling um so that's
where um I try to to lean on is that
when when the state looks at the
opportunities that uh of just
maintaining the infrastructure that we
have at the park we're not really
looking at expansion necessarily or
additional acquisition uh those kinds of
things it's really just trying to kind
of maintain things that we have now such
as an 85y old aerial Tramway um that we
would like to see another 40 years uh
happen uh that is that is critical to uh
the New Hampshire's economy I think so
you know if if that goes away so do you
know the 100,000 visitors that rote it
each year um and you know I think the
ripple effect through that would would
be strongly felt throughout the region
so that's just a you know an example um
we have some parks Greenfield state park
right now was closed for the last year
because we're doing a long overdue um
arpa projects there for for utilities so
that Community I'm sure is feeling uh
some level of impact that um thousands
and thousands of campers and visitors
aren't aren't coming to to the park
anymore representative Ms thank thank
you Mr chairman and thank you
commissioner and director for coming in
um I I really don't have a question I
just wanted to U thank you for all the
work that um you have done and continue
to do at Hampton Beach I mean I'm glad
you brought up the uh
improvements um they're spectacular and
it it has led to a lot of uh development
so thank thank you for your work you're
doing there and um you know the only
other thing I would comment on is that
um everybody is very thankful and um
proud of the lifeguards uh at the beach
and the work that they do um and I think
they were ranked as the best they won
some award is the more yeah thank you
more we're going to need a whole another
building just to house the trophies that
they continue to accumulate there um no
um and that's a a stat that's on the
sheet here that I was remiss on on
mentioning here so um this summer there
was 166 ocean rescues 100 or 85 first
and major medical incidents that that
happened through that Squad they
continue to um I think be one of you
know the most professional um groups
lifeguard groups uh on on the on the
east coast and we continue to strive to
do that um they're probably out there
swimming in their wet suits right now
and training um and also on here um
which also gets overlooked as well too
we had 42 Mountain rescues at Mount
manad that our staff uh the park staff
are involved in so we work closely with
fishing game and other First Responders
but our staff in the park system are the
First Responders cuz we're there already
when a lot of these things are happening
and then also just uh you know thank you
for the support that you offer to our
local businesses the uh Seafood Festival
being the the biggie um that means a lot
to uh local businesses and um I've been
there for almost 30 years now and seen
how it's grown and it's become uh quite
the event and yeah thanks for your help
thank you
Wilson I'm going to invite Patrick
Hackley up he's our state Forester and
lands good and he loves wearing a tie
when
he's I don't like ties but I try to pick
the best ones when I come to see you
here at the
legislature yes um thank you for the
opportunity to speak with you my name is
Patrick Hackley I'm the director for the
division of forest and
um I've made sure that you have lots of
reading material in my handout so I'll
go through some of the metrics in that
report and then I'm happy to take any
questions you might
have so our our division is we we're
basically the land managers for the
state um the state owns approximately
220,000 Acres we manage about 170,000
Acres of just what what I would call
dncr reservations and those are
scattered Parcels across the state from
our 40,000 acre uh Nash stream tract up
in the North Country to U scattered
small tracks uh we one of the largest
state forest we have in the south is the
pisga state forest that's 13,000 Acres
uh Bear Brook State Park in Allenstown
is 10,000 and then Puckaway I believe is
around
5,000 so we have a modest staff about 52
people uh and we are quite diverse
within the division of forest and lands
we're comprised of eight bureaus or
units as it says in the in the report
Forest management Land Management Forest
protection planning and Community
forestry natural heritage Forest Health
and Communications and there's a page
for each one of those bureaus in this um
small but meaty report I've given you um
and we also have a strategic partnership
with UNH Cooperative Extension unlike
other states where they have um what
they call service Foresters that provide
uh free consultation to private land
owners we don't have that in New
Hampshire so we partner with our friends
at UNH Cooperative Extension we actually
provide them with some uh financial
support to do Outreach and education to
the public and we also partner with them
on a lot of workshops so they're kind of
our
education uh Outreach arm our Foresters
do just that they do Forest management
and that's what they specifically uh are
focused on um some of the just some of
the highlights from this past fiscal
year now this is the end of fiscal year
2024 so that was of course at the end of
um June uh We've we've managed on
average about 2,000 acres a year this
year is a little lower we we generate
about $11.75 million in Timber Revenue
um we are working on a 5,000 acre Forest
Legacy project we partner with the US
Forest Service they have a program
called Forest Legacy and that allows us
to purchase the development rights this
is a willing Buy willing seller
situation where they want to sell the
development rights um and this conserves
land and conserves working Forest um and
kind of contributes to that forested
landscape we've all come to appreciate
here in New Hampshire um well our forest
Health uh when I call these bureaus they
range anywhere from about 15 people to
about three our smallest one's about
three people Forest Health is one of
those smaller um bureaus um but they
they're small But Mighty they do a lot
of work they they conduct aerial surveys
across the state for uh insect and
disease outbreaks um they do research
they consult with land owners regarding
Forest health
issues and uh they're they're a key part
of what we do for the public and for our
state forest um natural heritage Bureau
I'm sure you've heard about so they're
housed under our division um they
conduct environmental reviews um
anywhere between three and 4,000 reviews
a year they also go out and inventory
for rare threatened or endangered plants
they keep a very significant uh database
of uh plants and as well as rare
threatened or endangered animal species
for fishing game we have a anou with
fishing game so they house the data for
those rare threatened or endangered
plants and of animals sorry um Urban and
Community forestry there's a nice
picture of uh AJ Dupri planting trees
they they visited about I think it was
well it says in here I think it was
close to 20 schools this year um
teaching kids how to care for trees
educating them um looks like they did um
18 schools this year they've um consult
with communities about um Urban trees
along streets um uh really an
educational program that they provide
and it's very well enjoyed there was
some recent press we had on that program
uh just this
week um Forest protection so um they're
are one of our more visible bureaus th
those are the forest rangers you see in
their shiny red pickup trucks that drive
around the state they do fire patrol
they assist uh significantly with the
communities to train and provide
equipment to them we have what we call a
federal excess program whereby we can
get um used fire equipment from the US
Forest Service and provide that to the
communities so they they're well
equipped to fight uh rural fires which
of course in New Hampshire that's
that's um considerable so they provide
training equipment and uh they also do
their own patrols for detection early
detection we because of the budget cuts
we won't be Staffing our fire Towers
this year we have 15 fir Towers across
the state from Pittsburgh down to
Milford um we did we were able thanks to
arpa funding we got a little slice of
the pie from our friends at Parks and
Recreation we got about 2.3 million so
we're able to renovate four
of our fire Towers our aging fir Towers
we replaced the cab and shored up the uh
the iron supports um last year it was
cardigan and bellnap mountains towers
and this year it was pitcher mountain
and fedal Hill and uh the we had done I
think in 2016 we had restored another
four with I guess it was Capital funding
at that time but we're able to put the
2.3 million in arpa funding to good use
so we're we're very pleased with that
the contractors did a wonderful job
unfortunately they'll be they'll be idle
this summer we won't be Staffing them um
and those are typically part-time uh
folks anyway but
um uh so Forest protection was very busy
this year as some of you know who
followed the news um New England
Southern New England was on fire quite a
bit this year nothing like our our uh
our neighbors out west and you know the
terrible things that are going on in
California of course but uh Oregon had a
number of wildfires that were remote our
Foresters we we call them mobilizations
we work through the US Forest Service
and we send our our firefighters out
there to assist them they get valuable
training um they help out our our uh our
states out there and then uh they can
bring that training back here to New
England um there was a Thousand Acre
fire in Massachusetts this this uh fall
it was one of the driest uh novembers on
record and uh it really um hit
Connecticut Massachusetts and um Vermont
had quite a few as well we'll send
engines we'll send uh Rangers uh
equipment and and it comes back to us
it's a it's a regional compact that we
belong to so when we have trouble and we
need folks um they'll send them down
from Quebec the Canadian maritimes from
the other states um so it's a very
really um uh beneficial uh cooperation
we have with with the other states and
and the Canadian
provinces uh Cooperative Extension as I
mentioned they're are our um education
partner I I won't go into the numbers
but uh you know hundreds of land owners
private land owners uh workshops to
Foresters
loggers um conservation groups um so
they they execute our mission in a whole
another
realm
um seedling program so we we run the
state Nursery that's under our forest
management Bureau um and I think Sarah
mentioned that in her comments earlier
we uh sell between 200 and 300 seedlings
300,000 seedings a year and uh it's it's
been in operation since 1910 so the
infrastructure is pretty old and as the
commissioner mentioned it was overdue
for some uh improvements so this is the
first season with a brand new irrigation
system and that was uh uh due largely to
arpa funding um the the new cooler rooms
is going to be Capital funding which we
had budgeted for over a year ago and
that will provide state-of-the-art space
to we we have to store the seedlings in
um in these um wax line bags uh for a
period of time so that when we're ready
to ship they're they stay fresh and
Alive of course so we U have to have a
good uh commercial cooler to store the
seedling so it'll be replacing that this
uh probably won't happen till September
of of um you know this coming fall um
but uh we have big plans to um renovate
the rest of the the structure it's an
old barn that we occupy there when we
when we sort the seedlings and U it's
going to improve efficiency and safety
and uh with we we've had Banner years in
terms of sales as well which is great
all that money goes back to the nursery
to fund the staff um materials uh we
we're very fortunate to have the forest
service provide grant funding as well
we've had a couple of Grants of 160,000
each and that's gone to towards U new
planting equipment um we've purchased
for the first time time in decades a new
tractor which we really needed a new
tractor a nice John Deere and uh our
Nursery manager is very happy to have
that to
use man I'm gonna get a sunburn over
here um so that's the
nursery um I'll just leave it there and
open it up for questions we've got a lot
of other divisions any questions
representative Ms thank you Mr chair and
thank you for coming in um last term I
served on science and
technology and um we had at least one
bill where uh people were coming in
talking
about
um um or organizations that come in and
try to uh to to um purchase land that
they can then offer to offset car as
carbon offsets yes yeah um and I was
just wondering if that's anything that
that you've gotten involved in or could
that be a potential new Revenue source
for you oh thanks for the question I'm
gonna be as brief as possible so those
those bills were aimed at um limiting
enrollment in carbon um due to the
controversy in the North country with
the large
landowner which created some economic uh
um uh issues with with the towns in ter
in terms of Timber tax wood supply and
logging jobs um many of the legislators
from the north North Country wanted to
see carbon credit programs uh go into a
moratorium if you will um it really
doesn't have to the land is a critical
part of it but it's really about the the
carbon that's uh sequestered and stored
in the trees and that's what um
companies and land owners are selling
are the the credits for for managing
carbon um so there is one one bill
there's a couple of bills that are
carbon related in the legislature this
year um one is to um allow towns to U
Levy a tax on the carbon that a land
owner if they decide not to cut their
trees and therefore forego the timber
tax this bill would enable towns to Levy
a tax because of their carbon credit
generation so that's one bill and then
there's another bill though it hasn't
hasn't been U introduced the committee
yet but they want to prohibit uh carbon
credit enrollment for any state lands
Municipal and County
lands yeah I gu I guess what I was
thinking I was thinking more of the fact
that you know the land that is in the
Parks yeah is already controlled by the
state correct um and is there an is
there an opportunity there to offer that
land as for carbon for carbon offset
credits right and this is controversial
um because
because of the um perception that it
impacts the economy there are proponents
that don't want to see the state
involved in carbon credit
Generation Um but carbon credit programs
and Timber harvesting are not an either
or they're a both and you can do both
and do it well without sacrificing jobs
that's my opinion um in my what I I know
about carbon credit programs you can do
both go
I'm just going to um just put a footnote
that because we are still negotiating
with Aurora um up at the Connecticut
Lakes
headquarters um we're not in a position
to talk policy at this point until we
feel settled and comfortable with an
agreement for that property um but there
it it it has become a a a Hot Topic and
one worthy of discussion um and an
understanding and so it's great to see
the state house um taking it on and and
having thorough discussions scientific
discussions economic discussions but as
far as the state position we're we want
to get through um these negotiations in
a successful positive way for the state
and then we can learn from the
I just had a quick question before I
forget um how many acres do you think
burned last year in New Hampshire and
years on average our our our burns are
typically less than 10 acres um but
we've been averaging a little over 200
230 uh fires per year the last few years
it's a concern
um I I don't I can't tell you off the
top of my head if that's more than we've
had in the past there are some numbers
on the forest Protection Bureau sheet
that will tell you what we had this past
year um but we're definitely concerned
because uh you whether you believe in
the global CH climate change or not our
climate has changed and there are hotter
Summers drier Falls I mean we we can't
um predict how many fires are going to
be each year but we do need to be
prepared so um but we can we can we can
get you that yeah I'm curious because
not only from the perspective of the
weather change but also New Hampshire I
believe manages their Forest pretty well
so I wanted to see uh that has to be a
big factor and how do we compare to
other states that don't manage the
forest like we do Wonder yeah we can get
back to you on that that'd be great um
representative eel and then
representative Ms thank you um first of
all I want to say that I've worked with
the Cooperative Extension Service quite
a bit and I think they're fantastic I'm
going to give a shout out to uh Tim
flurry right here um but just on the
issue of Forest Health I mean we talked
there a little bit about fires I mean
it's just alarming the number of
invasive
uh bugs among other things and I
just can you give us your feelings on
the Forest Health and the future and
yeah it's very I mean I'm just looking
at your on the beaches you thought the
beaches would be safe but apparently
they're not even safe well I think that
beach picture is just a survey of a
survey going on but um we we definitely
have seen an increase in um there's been
a recent wave of spongy moth formerly
called Gypsy moth that has killed some
trees in New Hampshire along with the
very late May Frost we had a few years
ago that did leave um a number of Acres
with dead particularly oak trees
um I would say we're still in very good
shape in terms of the health of our
forest um invasive species plant species
is another concern it it chokes the
undergrowth of of desirable native
species um we have a very active uh
Forest Health Bureau um they're
monitoring for um the other one that
we've had in the state for a while is um
Hemlock wad
delid uh so that's that kind of comes
and goes this cold snap we're having
right now will actually have a an impact
on the population that'll knock back
those egg masses and we'll see that
population not as strong this um spring
which is a good thing um we are
monitoring for Spruce budworm which was
devastating back in the 70s our
neighbors in Quebec have been dealing
with um millions of Acres of of
defoliation from uh Spruce budworm and
it has showed up in Main the last
several years and there's an effort now
to increase detection and suppression
efforts in Maine and we're partnering
with them to do the same in Northern New
Hampshire where our Spruce fur forests
are
predominant um but I would say overall
we're we're okay the climate change does
affect population but it's not a cause
and effect it just influences these
insects and diseases were here before
for the most part um many of them not
all but many of them and so they EV flow
with the weather pattern but it's not
all a cause for concern I think we're
overall we're doing very well
representative msen I'll uh caution that
we only have 20 minutes left and we have
a few more directors to meet so sure
okay sorry um so I want to just follow
up on the on the the you know the
questions about you know fire damage and
fire risk um and you know given given
the fact that we did have such a warm
fall we're we're having a pretty dry
winter so far I mean uh we'll see what
happens in the next couple months but so
far it's been pretty dry um you know it
I I guess I'm I'm just a little
concerned or or wondering why we would
be not not Staffing fire to
Towers um and if we're not Staffing them
within with people are we doing
something else to kind of monitor the
situation are we using technology
or well
um we'll probably do what we can with
the Rangers we have we have um we still
have uh nine full-time forest rangers
who will increase their patrols to the
extent possible um we do get Federal
funding we have some grant funding that
can assist in in monitoring and and
patrolling um and we do flights we do
aerial flights um with the Civil Air
Patrol so we may increase to the extent
our budget will allow we'll try to um
thank you director hyley
thanks okay next up Mindy
Atwood Mindy serves as the deputy
director of the State library but in
absence of a state librarian she's
wearing multiple hats and keeping our
State Library accessible and
open good afternoon um as the
commissioner mentioned my name is Mindy
Atwood I am the assistant State
librarian and the administrator for
Library operations at the State Library
um I do just want to take one moment and
give um homage to Michael York who is
the state librarian for 25 years and he
would want me to remind all of you that
we are the oldest State library in the
nation we began in 1717 which is pretty
neat um there are some rsas that govern
the New Hampshire State Library uh 201a
talks about the State Library shall be
the official clearing ing house of state
government
information um 202b one talks about the
legislature finding that providing
citizens with access to public documents
will allow increased citizen involvement
in state policies and Empower citizens
to participate in state policy decision
making um and then there's other
statutes of course that sort of more
specifically outline the duties of the
State Library um by the number and you
will find that in your handout that is
in the page I think it's ironic that the
librarian brought a one pager and the
forest and lands Guy brought like a four
or five pager just
saying that's right that is some irony
right there
uh um so we have about a half a million
volumes um at the State Library they are
primarily uh state and federal
government documents uh we do have a
small collection of Library information
science Publications um we have a
biography collection and then primarily
we try to collect about uh books about
New Hampshire and books by New Hampshire
authors and any New Hampshire resident
can get a State library card so if you
don't have a State library card please
feel free to stop by we'd be happy to
have you sign up for one um we are in a
40,000 squ foot building with 22
full-time staff and between five and
seven part-time and substitute drivers
um and I'll talk more about that in a
moment um we have many longtime
employees uh our four senior staff have
an average of more than 15 years of
experience at the New Hampshire State
library and I'm I'm the new kid on the
Block and I'm constantly Amazed by their
breadth of knowledge and and their
dedication um we received between 1.3
and $1.5 million in federal funding from
The Institute of Museum and Library
services or imls
um to receive these federal funds we
must both maintain a 50% match of state
to federal funds um and then we're also
required to produce a five-year plan
that outlines the programs that will be
subed with federal funds and the larger
Improvement in goals that will result
from those programs and I'm happy to
follow up by email and send you that
plan but again it's sort of lengthy um
so and then we also support New
Hampshire's 234 public libraries 70% of
which do serve a population of fewer
than 8,000
residents um so we also provide services
to the state government really we are
collectors we collect and make
accessible to both elected officials and
New Hampshire citizens things like the
sessions law index government documents
state agency Publications newspapers
from all across the state um and I did
as a librar and I just had to bring an
example so this is a book um Big Trees
of Northern New England short hikes to
the biggest trees in Northern
Massachusettes Vermont New Hampshire and
Maine now right now this book is widely
available in our public librar it
published in 2002 was very popular
there's lots of copies of it but in 25
years or in 50 years I would lay good
money that the New Hampshire State
Library might be the only holder of this
book and it documents a moment in time
for these big trees that in 25 50 years
may very well be gone um so that is a
big part of what we try to
do um we also offer reference Health to
the office of legislative Services as
well as individual legislators and other
state agencies um we also offer servi
services to New Hampshire citizens and I
really feel like in this way we're
conductors because we help people
navigate their own government um we're
also the foremost resource in the state
for genealogy research and uh we really
have the largest collection for people
who are looking to do genealogy research
and we have a wonderful story of a a
young man who came looking for some
genealogy information um about his
birthfather and our reference librarian
Charles Shipman helped him find this
information and in fact um this young
man saw for the first time a picture of
his birth father he had never seen his
birth father before so that is some of
what we we do we also have an ask a
librarian service on our website and we
also of course take Walkins at the State
library and we really as I said help
citizens navigate um state government um
Elder and disability services safety
questions motor vehicle questions
current use and land use questions a lot
of times people get a letter citing 151
dasi colon 2 and they don't understand
what it means so they call and we
explain to them that it talks about um
the patient family or to the patient
family or Guardian that whatever
facility their family member is in
reasonably believes that the person's
eligible for Medicaid and it tells them
how to file Medicaid but people see the
statue cited and they have no idea
what's happening or saf-c 204 period 04
which is related to hearings for license
suspension for drivers under the age of
20 who have had a moving violation and
um sometimes people don't really know
what that's all about um and we also are
connectors we facilitate resource
sharing through the maintenance of a
Statewide catalog which provides access
to the more than 6 million items that
are in our Collective New Hampshire
libraries um we as the commissioner
mentioned have an inter Library Loan
program that moves more than 160,000
items a year uh we have five van on the
road Monday Tuesday Thursday and Friday
and on Wednesdays we have six vans on
the road those vans cover within the
state more than 220,000 miles a
year um we also um so as an example in
the small But Mighty town of Mont Vernon
population
2,674 we support no fewer than eight
book groups that run through that
Library um another example ex Le is that
we um do host the New Hampshire
downloadable books Consortium which uh
allows our citizens access to um shared
econtent um so we do provide a wide
variety of functions and service for
government citizens and the public
libraries of New Hampshire I happy to
take your
questions yes uh personally uh I would
like to know amongst the Six Million
items that you have do you have any
coins and any coins coins do you have
any a lot of libraries have big coin
collections and I'm a collector so I was
Wonder I've never been in there and just
wondering do you have any point
interesting well first of all I would
say you should come and our reference
librarian will answer that question much
more a than I I'm sure we have books
about coin collecting but coins that
were held by libraries I would guess
they would feel those were very precious
and they might not want to share those
out but you could perhaps go visit and
to piggyback on that because I see a lot
of untapped potential with the treasures
that we are tasked to protect um we have
recently hired a curator who is here
with us today Jen who is her office is
in the library and she's pouring over so
many drawers and cabinets where our
staff over the years have felt things
are safer locked up uh and we're
discovering a lot of stories and
untapped potential to educate the public
about our Collective history so we will
get back to you on coins but we're
discovering a lot of stuff yeah if you
find any let me know I I'll let you know
what they are okay cool thank are there
any other questions for the director the
deputy director no no thank you so much
thank you thanks Wendy up next is our
arts
division and we have Adele who
oversees the New Hampshire State Council
on the Arts good afternoon um so I just
wanted to share this Sarah had mentioned
that it is our 60th anniversary AR uh
this year we were created in 1965
through RSA 19 currently we have eight
positions dedicated to the division of
Arts four of which are federally funded
four are state funded one is currently a
general fund position that is vacant and
is likely to stay that way until uh
budget decisions and such there are 15
different people who are volunteers that
make up our New Hampshire State Council
on the Arts and they are all dedicated
to
really helping to enhance and strengthen
and move our strategic plan Mission
Vision and goals of making sure that we
are taking care of the economic social
and cultural needs and changing
landscapes in New Hampshire and all of
those 15 people are also just uh they're
nominated by the governor and then
approved by the executive
Council we are primarily funded by the
Nea and then with there is a match
requirement for that Grant so in the
2325 fiscal year that was one of the
first times that the council was able to
match General funds with our federal
fund award and so the match piece is a
complicated one for us at the Arts in
that so let's say if we only had
$750,000 of General funds to match our
federal award we would then that would
be 250,000 Less in general and then we
couldn't accept 250,000 Less in the the
federal fund so really it can be a
$500,000 loss overall for what we're
Hampshire we have eight different Grant
areas which we gave out over 220 Grant
Awards this past year they are in arts
in health arts in residency and Schools
traditional Arts folk life
apprenticeships youth art projects arts
for Community engagement public value
Partnerships with our performing art
venues at meet our nonprofit requirement
Arts conservative license plate Grant
Awards as well as individual artist
entrepreneurial grants our grant process
is adjudicated with um a panel each time
of community members as well as those um
some of our Council folks and those
materials are reviewed and approved as
is appropriate and if the award is over
$10,000 to any individual organization
then it comes to the governor and
approval I'm trying to be mindful of
time so if you have any questions in any
area please let me know any questions
sure representative evil yeah so I'm
just looking at this Arts and Cultural
production satellite
account so it says that we're 48th among
all states in employment growth and I
mean could you just explain a little bit
what looking at this is this not you
oh don't have it in front of you no I'm
sorry I don't have that in front of me
umk Arts and Cultural production
satellite account this is conducted by
the Bureau of economic oh I see analysis
it's National
assessment so it does it just like
reflect investment in arts compared to
other states this is the feds assessing
our investments in every state comparing
and contrasting and yeah we're at
on the lower end of that
much okay thank You Adele last but not
least we've got the division of
historical
resources Representatives I'm Ben Wilson
I'm the director of the division of
historical resources and the state uh
historic preservation officer um what we
don't do is yoga on the beach or measure
trees um or poetry out loud things like
that but uh like my colleagues uh behind
me we do touch every community in the
state in some fashion um we are a
division of 10 staff our funding is 6040
60% Federal funding and 40% General
funds uh so that's uh six staff under
feds and four under General funds um our
major program is reviewing compliance so
any project going on in the state that
has uh an EPA permit for uh sewer water
um uh has Federal monies um through the
um Highway bill or state funding going
into infrastructure projects um we
review all those projects we do nearly
2,000 uh reviews a year um and that
takes up a great deal of our time time
um in your packet I've provided uh sort
of a brief overview of what the the
division does as well as our latest
newsletter that has some year-end
numbers um and I'm just going to quickly
go through our programs um that are in
that uh that's in that packet um so
aside from review and compliance uh we
manage the national register and state
Register programs um we manage the
federal tax credit program so uh
developers trying to get their finan put
together to make their projects work
specifically in housing um that uh tax
credit program can be a huge boost and
make things
happen uh we manage uh our certified
local government uh grant program uh we
have to dedicate 10% of our Federal
grant to uh grants to communities that
have uh included historic preservation
and a Heritage commission um in their uh
planning um uh we spend about
$250,000 or give away
$250,000 annually in Moose plate grants
those are uh grants that usually average
between 10 and
$20,000 uh and they specifically go to
municipalities for uh locally owned uh
publicly owned buildings and uh burial
grounds and other significant historic
resources uh in a in a
town um we house the state archaeology
um the state archaeologist has to
oversee um basically all reviews of of
the projects that I mentioned earlier um
the state archae state archaeologist
also uh operates a field School uh over
the course of a month in the summer um
those field schools bring together
volunteers and professional
archaeologists to do um archaeological
digs and investigations um primarily on
state land
and again primarily in State Park uh
lands um which is a huge
benefit um the say archaeologist also
has to deal with unmarked Graves so if a
developer or a project discovers um an
unmarked grave bones and that sort of
thing um which happens more often than
you would guess um the state
archaeologist gets involved with the um
uh with the state police and the um uh
with other folks involved and um has to
determine whether or not it's a historic
grave or um possibly a crime scene um
those sorts of things so it's a it's a
big it's a big deal it's a big position
um that he manages very very well um we
manage approximately 40 easements on
properties and buildings um uh probably
our most significant one is canterburry
Shaker Village we oversee the entire
campus there and um monitor all the
works uh good works that they do up
there uh we manage in uh cooperation
with do the historic Highway marker
program so all the beautiful signs that
you see on the side of the roads um uh
those all come through our um our office
as well as
dot um we work closely with All State
agencies where federal and state funds
are being spent um as I mentioned uh we
work closely with also with our sister
uh organizations in the state um for
instance um the New Hampshire
preservation Alliance as well as um the
um lchip program um we uh sit on their
review committees and um and then also
manage a lot of their easements that uh
come with those projects um that's sort
of it in a nutshell um again in your uh
packet you have other information that I
questions are there any questions rep
representative
Lehman go ahead as long as it's not
about archaeology specifically because I
don't have my degree in
that it's nice to see you good to see
you nice to see of course um I noticed
in your covered letter you said you had
about a 4% cut in your budget have you
been asked for additional Cuts or is
that what you've been told for percent
is adequate thank you um so what I
handed out is what is um publicly
available um and was due in November
this was our presentation um Chris
Marino who's with us um has all of the
numbers on a spreadsheet there has been
no other final analysis we have gone
through several
exercises um with different numbers but
this is the only um you know public
budget number that we have put together
uh for discussion all right thank you
thank you Mr
chairman well thank you for an excellent
presentation appreciate all the input
thank you um we do have I know you you
all like numbers so I will ask Chris
Marino to pass out some of these
spreadsheets for you for your review
please follow up with us with any
specific questions and I'm wondering if
our archaeologists could also see if
they have any coins for you to look at
so we'll check on that that would be
great thank you thank you all is this
what we already have this uh
yeah okay thank you very much all right
so we are here for uh office of
professional lure and
certification um just before we get
started I I uh before I left um I Heard
representative
muns be recognized and he said I don't
have a question
but so we don't that would be where I
would stop
you because you know we don't really
have time
to anyways for speeching and that sort
all
right thank you yeah please introduce
your right good afternoon members of the
committee uh just for the record my name
is Deana jurus executive director office
of professional lure and with
me Heather Kelly director of
operations so we've handed out a
presentation kind of giving you an
overview of the office and then
answering the specific questions that
were posed via email um so I'm just
going to go ahead and walk through this
any really um specific numbers questions
I will probably defer to Heather um but
happy to F any questions that you have
so again just overview the office of
professional licensure and
certification um the vision and mission
statements are here we're just looking
at Public Health welfare and safety um
and the public Trust of the citizens of
the State of New Hampshire um so just a
guiding principle on that first page I
will um I will move at a fairly high
level happy to get into details if you
have questions but want to um make sure
I respect your time and many of you are
aware probably well aware of this the
organization at this point so the office
oversees the administration of over 50
occupational licensing boards councils
and commissions within the state of New
Hampshire uh we don't give a specific
number because nearly every legislative
session it changes uh some come some go
um presently there are seven advisory
boards as opposed to the independent
regulatory board so it's a slightly
different um operational structure there
um they the on the first page it said
over 200,000 individuals I believe the
number in 2024 was 212 and and change
212,000 um with the population increase
my back of the napkin math needs to
change I used to say about 20% of the
state I think it's a little less than
that now with the increase um but I will
bone up on that for future uh
legislative presentations um staff
largely assists boards councils and
commissions with two major functions so
it's licensing individuals who wish to
practice in New Hampshire and ensuring
compliance with the laws through
investigations or inspections we average
about 100 complaints month and we
annually um I like to say the uh this
it's a very regulatory office um the way
that thing like we incur costs is that
people request a license that's required
by law or they end up violating law or
rule that is um required for them to do
their work so um we're not launching
extra programs uh this really is just a
response and we're always looking back
to the statute I've said in previous
presentations I will say again if the
law says it we do it if it doesn't we
don't and uh we're consistently looking
that as we're working through processes
um anyway if it's streamlining or just
doing review of rules anything like that
we're always going back to the statute
to just say what is the authority do we
have what do we have to do if we don't
have to do it by law we're not doing it
um so just on uh slide four the
structure in purpose so we have the
administrative clerical business
processing recordkeeping support um to
boards councils and commissions um so
that takes several different forms the
First Column enforcement is a division
which there's investigations and
prosecutions there there's licensing and
board Administration which is another
division so we have board administrator
um folks who help with agendas
organizing board members we have 25300
volunteers that are in and out of the
office serving on these boards it's
quite the operation um and then
licensing as well they're reviewing
those credentials and then comping so
ensuring um compliance with continuing
education if there are um facilities
requirements um cosmetology shops would
be one where there's inspections that
there's requirements they have to meet
there's routines inspections completed
for that then the director of operations
which is Heather um you have human
resources Finance it contracts project
management all of those pieces there in
addition reporting directly to the
executive director we have um general
counsel so there's agency counsel for
the office and then we have positions
that are just for board counsel so those
are attorneys that are providing advice
to boards during board meetings and then
the hearings Bureau we have
administrative law judges there are two
of those currently and a hearings clerk
so if things are moving through
adjudication the board said as finders
of fact I'll get into a few more of
those specifics but we have an
administrative law judge used to be
called the hearings officer who presides
over that and makes the the legal
determination there I will just pause
there if there's any questions I'm happy
to keep going just want to give an
opportunity there uh how many total
employees do you have I'm authorized for
120 presently I don't have a headcount
you we are not at20 I can
confirm I won't read go ahead I'm sorry
I won't read through this whole slide
but just to give a a sense of the
executive director responsibilities so
statutorily it's kind of broken in these
are responsib abilities of the boards
council's commissions and then the
executive director meaning the office so
there supervis supervision of Staff
employment of appropriate
personnel examination processing and
approval of licenses or
denial um investigation of complaints of
professional misconduct we maintain the
official record so 91a records requests
are handled by the office not the
individual boards were also tasked with
coordinating rulemaking in 2024 the
office was respons for 70 um no excuse
me 27 not 72 27% of the proposals filed
in the ru making
register in the entire State I will
proudly say we have one full-time and
two part-time rules Personnel um I like
to joke what I don't know what other
departments are doing we we're doing it
with three um all joking aside there's
obviously a lot of there but that that's
a hefty lift for us that the ru making
process is is quite extensive there um
again maintain Ming confidentiality and
then we have our annual report which is
available on our website also happy to
forward to the committee if you'd like
to have that right in your email inbox
homepage again in slide six just giving
the uh board responsibilities so they um
adopt the rules per each profession so
essentially the board set the criteria
for lure that are objective and then the
office processes applications in light
of those objective criteria if there is
a question um something is unclear that
can be brought to the boards for their
expertise um but largely we are able to
process those I'm happy to say that over
80% of licenses were processed within um
a 30-day window um which is excellent uh
it used to be a lot longer time frame
than that so as the criteria become more
objective we're streamlining processes
getting staff well trained we're able to
move those really quickly there's no
backlog of Licensing applications
presently um again there are 212 plus
active licensing in
2024 we issue an average and again the
math is some weeks are very busy some
weeks are slower for renewals because
it's based on the date of issuance not a
birthday or a set date and statute for
most boards but ends up being about
2,000 to 3,000 licenses a week and
currently our customer service team
answers 95 to 99% of all calls our wait
time is about 30 seconds and about and
100% of daily emails I'm really excited
to tell you about that um that we've
been really working on those processes
uh this time last year those numbers
were not even close to that so um been a
lot of work on that side of the house um
the enforcement division is in the
middle of a review of all complaints for
legal viability and to do some data
cleanup so there's a um a new director
her name is Sarah Rogers of enforcement
we're working to streamline processes
collaborate with boards there was a lot
of data cleanup that needed to happen so
when we were looking through um and if
you look in our annual report you will
see there are some numbers that are um
they're just not quite right and so
we're trying to do the cleanup to make
sure we have an accurate count just in
general um we are making good progress I
anticipate in within the next month to
have that completed um so we will have
some good information there as well and
then I already touched on this piece
with ro making responsible for over 25%
of initial proposals in the r making
register in
2024 because of the nature of this
process you guys are all familiar with
it these Ru making takes a long time
when you add a board into the process it
adds about five it could add up to five
months of time that it takes to get a a
rule from the initial proposal to
adopted just because of the length of
time for review hearings public comment
boards work working back and forth so
we're looking at a 13-month process so
and we have 57 boards so the we're still
working to update rules in light of HB
655 which was a major reorganization and
then 1095 in 2024 so we are actively
tracking that working with boards um but
there's the the lag is there there is at
least a full year lag of when the rules
have caught up with those statutory
changes just because of the sheer volume
and then we also have a staff member
presently working on um in RSA 310
there's a specific mandate for rule
making specific to military service
members experience and working on rules
for each board so we're also working
through that
presently um I'm going to be moving more
into source of funds and those specific
questions so if we have operational is
happy to kind of pause representative Ms
thank you Mr chair thank you thaning my
question um the the backlog in rules
um uh you mentioned the boards getting
involved but are there other um things
getting in the way I mean you know do
you need more staff is there a
technology uh issue um you know is there
opportunities for AI for example to
speed it up what what's your assessment
of you know I mean do you have the
resources you need to get the to get the
job done or is basically my question
yeah I I'm I would say I'm currently
evaluating that it's hard to say we're
not getting a lot done in terms of just
the volume trying to evaluate currently
we have two part-time drafters is that
is the makeup of one full-time and two
part-time the right kind of mix um We
additionally we do have a software for
rule making that um that helps us has
helped us streamline those processes
really provides clarity mean make sure
that we're keeping track of things um we
rolled that out I think we've been using
that for just about a year is that right
um so that's dramatically improved our
process um in that regard um still
evaluating what the resources will be
needed I guess the other question is am
I going to undergo a full um you know
statutory revision of the makeup of the
office every 3 years uh or is it going
to you know not that there's changes
around the edges but the the kind of
just the dramatic shift over the last
three years I don't anticipate that
churn continuing so what I don't want to
do is staff way up and then get to a
stasis you know so trying to evaluate do
we just need to get over the hump it is
something I'm actively looking at um yes
thank you so just getting on to so slide
seven with source of funds um the oplc
has not received General funds in the
last five years so 2018 was the last
year that they received General funds to
fund its operation we currently have a
dedicated fund um that was established
and here we list House Bill 409 which in
2023 allows the oper the agency to
operate more efficiently and effectively
so it was happening prior to that is the
office was lapsing back into the general
fund um but starting with 0 and making
payroll is very challenging um so the
idea was to have some amount it's up to
$3 million to roll over year toe it's
all still spent on agency operations so
that is the current function it's
entirely
self-funded um and has a dedicated fund
which any of you who are on the
dedicated funds committee would have
heard from us at late
fall um so pursuant to 3105 Revenue that
we receed from licensing fees um is
assessed by various boards and
commissions and it'll be credited to
special dedicated non collapsing fund
appropriated just a quick bullet point
on any arpa funds because that was one
of the questions the committee was
interested in
oplc was um partnered with doit the
Department of Information Technology who
technically holds this funding so it is
an oplc project but we are not managing
that money it is funds from it was
appropriated to that office so that's
the
6669 million for the new licensing
system implementation uh we have daily
calls with them it's um moving forward
well we um The Hope is once we've built
one board one licensing board I'm not an
IT person but it kind of just becomes
copy and paste here's the other boards
and tweaking around the edges so we are
currently planning our go live mandatory
date for the first board and then
working timelines into that so we're
excited about that certainly we'll have
that money spent well before the 2026
deadline there um we will not be using
general funds to replace them um there
so no risk there at
all um and then we just have our
strategic objectives mostly for your
information we want to complete that
migration continue to establish internal
controls I'd like to look at an a public
docketing system for the enforcement
side of the house again the so our new
licensing platform I think we could
integrate the two and if a member of the
public has made a complaint they would
receive a number and they could see the
status of that complaint currently um
well by law we can't provide any details
but I would like to just say yes it's
under investigation or it has been
dismissed I would like to be able to
have that information publicly that's an
IT thing it's another um it would be a c
kind of a capital expense not not in the
very technical term but it it would take
money and that budgetary consideration
is um ongoing and then establishing an
in-house status Center so looking at
Workforce Trends we have a lot of data
in the office again not to misuse it or
to use it against anyone who does not
want their information to be shared but
we'd love to be able to provide
Workforce data that's helpful as the
forward the last piece here um aside
from our contact information is the new
positions so their request was again
dating back um how many new positions
were funded so um Heather put this
together for me looking at their request
in in the current budget and then the
last two uh before that budgeting
predates both of us um the records are
unclear so we wanted to give you
accurate information here um so we
created 11 per 11 permanent positions in
the 2223 budget that are currently
funded created six in the last bium and
then requesting eight temporary
positions to become permanent in this
next budget
process the piece to keep in mind there
is this the office was only created 10
not even 10 years ago and as statutory
mandates increased and the
responsibilities of the office increased
the staff were needed to do those things
so um the division of enforcement was
created therefore we needed people in
the division of enforcement they they
they weren't there before um it had been
that work had been done at the AG's
office previously now it was in in house
same with it the in to maintain the
licensing system for all these boards it
was needed to be there um and then again
the independent hearing piece of it so
just for your context there this is
um as those mandates came through
providing appropriate Staffing to
execute to really to accomplish our
mission of fulfilling all statutory
mandates there
so aside from the headcount which I can
get back to the committee on the
specific number that we have right now
um happy to take any other
questions I'll start with one so um I
see here that your fiscal year
2025 budget is um let's see where is it
here about $16
million which seems to me on the high
side for 120
employees um is it all are you spending
on something else or maybe it's this
computer system or or am I not
multiplying right so the the new
licensing system is the r money that's
kind of that infusion onetime spending
so that wouldn't be included in that
piece there um I would my understanding
is about 70% of our office's salaries
and benefits so that ends up being
2223 million there and then there are
other Associated costs um Heather can
speak more specifically to the numbers I
don't I don't think it's particularly
high but it also includes another data
cated fund that we have which is the PHP
program and that is approximately uh a
couple about a million
so that's included in that budget figure
and additionally our rent uh figure is
included in that which is predominantly
high I can get that exact figure for you
okay yeah maybe we'll you'll give us
some more detailed uh um statements okay
good so the p i representative Lee thank
you Mr chairman welcome so uh two years
ago the past director submitted a number
of policy board changes which many of
them were not met with a lot of
enthusiasm by the finance committee do
you plan to bring forth a lot of changes
in this coming budget
cycle um I know I my position has been
and actually I think many
representatives can say I said can you
give me a year to just do what you've
asked me to do like what's in the law
can we can we roll it out can I get
through this rules lag can my processes
catch up and let's let's just do what's
in the law now and then let's see what
needs to happen do we need to change it
again so uh I'm saying please send as
little as possible my way I'm not asking
for any even things that we're seeing
that we're saying maybe this is a kind
of a cleanup technical Bill trying to
get it to drive uh I have told my staff
put it on a list we're not asking for it
this year I I'm uh we don't need any
more work presently yeah further
question Mr chairman thank you uh do you
have any fee increases in your budget
obviously so you don't run on General
funds you run on the fees you collect do
you have any proposed increases or are
you going to leave the fees
flat I can't say definitively because
we're still in the budget process and
because my fees because I'm entirely fee
funded whatever I'm authorized to budget
I will have to raise in fees to have the
balanced budget there so I I don't know
what that's going to look like I can't
give a definitive answer I'm going to
ask if you would allow me to have
Heather just talk through the the
statutory mandate that we have for
setting the fees appropriately so you
kind of get a sense of the formula that
we use when we're making these
considerations so if if that's okay with
you to give a little
context so the agency is not authorized
to collect more than 12 125% of the
board expenses so what we do is we take
all indirect costs divide them amongst
the lensy account for each board and
then attribute any direct cost to the
board so mechanical inspectors for
example are attributed directly just to
to the mechanical board from there we
determine the ratio and then make
appropriate adjustments on the fee
there thank you Mr
chairman thank you thank you Mr chairman
I have a few questions um do is there a
list of the license fees that are
charged and then um how do they compare
to other states are they pretty
consistent or is there a real Delta
between certain States the the current
license fees are largely in one place
which would be the the oplc rule so PLC
1002 is the chapter that you could look
at it has just a grid not every fee is
included in there because there are some
that we have not yet engaged in rule
making to set a fee for newer boards
that have come over or newer license
types that were created in statute
additionally um actually that's part of
what we're working through with this
whole the whole budget process now is
that the office has newly the the
statutory authority to set those fees is
now newly with the office it was
previously with the boards and so now
it's clear that the office sets all of
those fees so there are some currently
that are in other parts of rule in other
chapters with boards and the idea would
be whatever ends up being filed would
all be in one place in those 10002s you
get a pretty good sense if you look at
it now it the plan is for it to be
comprehensive in the proposal that we're
the role that we file okay and how do
those compare with other states because
the the the fees from what I heard you
say the fees are set really driven by
the expenses of the particular board so
how do those expenses compare with you
know other states do they have the same
level of expenses more or less I know
Heather's team has done some analysis on
this I we probably won't speak to
specifics but I'll let her give you a
general sense if she has that on the top
of mind I know for some specific boards
like Board of Medicine we are
substantially lower however our Board of
Medicine uh is well over their ratio uh
but we do have a comprehensive list if
you would like we can Bo that as well
okay thank you and then uh a couple
other questions you mentioned that you
have some positions open um what type of
positions are
they really spans the agency there
silver vacancies with our LSR or our
licensing um service representative so
that those would be the people on phones
and emails and issuing licenses license
clerk there um I have a an attorney
position vacant I
have um the yes an investigator position
vacant an enforcement I have um
a yes our public information
officer we have we have some other
positions that are um proposed to be
unfunded so those are vacant obviously
because we're not going to fill them
right now if we're not planning to fund
to fund them in going forward um some
board administrator so again that team
that supports each board there so it
really kind of runs across the the whole
piece of it through all divisions yeah I
was just interested if there more
professional positions entry level but
and then my final question is you
mentioned um the the number of
complaints you get are those really
geared at one particular um occupation
or they is that pretty much the
complaints spread across many of them
the primary two the largest two
complaints would be medicine and Board
of Nursing oh okay thank you those would
be the two highest by far yes all right
thank you
yep thank you Mr chair thank you for
coming in um I get the fact that you
don't want us to give you more work to
do um is there things that are in
statute already
that you would like to see removed from
statute that you know basically you you
really don't understand the the
rationale reason for it it's just
whenever you know I gu I guess I'm not
asking for you to run down a list but I
mean my point is you know if there are
things like that I think that would be
useful for us to know because maybe we
can help you out okay I think what I'd
like to say is uh I really um having
served in the legislature and on the
governor's staff with the former
Administration and then currently in
this role um I just really understand
I'm not in a policy-making role I just I
implement the law that you give me um so
I may have a lot of personal opinions
about what I think should be happening I
might have some ideas for operational um
consolidation and support there but my
position really is I I will implement
the law that you give me whether or not
I think that's the way that it should be
so I I do hesitate to make a policy
recommendation just out of Defence for
the the separation of the branches which
I know is not satisfying to you but I I
really do hesitate to to do that in this
seat okay um I guess I guess oh am am I
all right yeah so um representative lean
was out of the room when we said we'll
allow a little back and forth just to
save time I was that's right yeah yeah
yeah so you know but if it gets to be
too much I'll I will you know impose my
will or so the the um push the button
the the the um this you mentioned that
the statute sets the maximum you can
charge is at
125% is that enough does that give does
that create problems where you where you
end up um you know having to absorb a
cost that you shouldn't have
to what we're currently evalu there are
like I mentioned there are some licenses
that by law we have to issue but we have
not engaged in Ru making yet to charge a
fee I I think there's broad consensus
that it does cost some amount of money
to process them so I don't anticipate a
challenge with setting that
appropriately for the credentials that
do not yet have a fee established from
the office the the challenge becomes for
us and where it's I mean it is not a
simple proposal because it's so
contingent on the budget is to say
whatever the bottom line amount is
anything that is not a direct cost is
divided by the boards the challenge for
us is to say we don't we we don't want
to go over
125% but we also don't want to be under
100% And I think that that is the piece
right now that we're looking at how do
you how do you level that out to say if
a
board um if the amount attributed to a
board is not covered by the fees from
that board um what is compliance with
that one that doesn't set necessarily a
minimum but then you do end up having
those subsidies potentially from other
boards and and what does that look like
and um that that's something we're
actively looking at and again the the
the budget is going to determine what
those fees how that looks if that makes
sense I'm I don't want to be koi with
you I'm just just trying to be straight
that leveling that out is is a challenge
yeah representative Camal thank you Mr
chair for the sake of efficiency are
there any commissions that you're on or
that your staff attends that really you
feel not worthwhile and it could save
your yourself or your staff some time
what commissions that you you've been
assigned to attend
yes I think uh director Kelly is on a
few I think they are more study
committee in nature they're not
longstanding like standing committees I
am currently appointed to the it Council
but that's my only role there I'm trying
to think off the top of my head I don't
think I have any
standing like long committees I think
that mostly it's the
shortterm what a couple months or like
the one-year study committee that we're
looking at I don't think we have any
those like ex official obligations at
this
point thank you we're just we're we're
asking that question of every Department
because we are on a mission to try to
reduce the amount of commissions so
again if I didn't expect you to give a
straight answer but if you do think of
it uh let the chairman know and we will
do everything we can to eliminate that
that commission as a person who worked
on boards and commissions appointments
goal representative Griffin I wonder if
you could go into a little more
who sets the
standards and what typically are they
for a profession in other words uh does
a profession have a an exam a person has
to pass to get licenses is that the
typical thing or or uh are you just a
administrator that gives a license out
or do you get involved in that exam
process oh yeah for any profession and
how does it work basically yeah happy to
get into that a little bit I may give
you a high level and defer to um
director Kelly here but um it really
does run the gamut so among those 57
boards we have about 200 different
license types so it really varies widely
right so between an MD and a pharmacy
tech and an LNA and a landscape
architect and an electrician it really
is widely different I think the thing
that's uniform is that these boards that
have Prof profession members of the
profession on them are the ones that are
setting the standard um the requirements
for that license many do have exams um
that are administered typically we have
a third-party vendor that administers
that exam uh that people can take
there's a difference to some boards
require people to apply and be approved
to sit for an exam then they can take
the exam if they pass then they are
licensed others their application you
take your exam you say hey I passed with
your application and then that's just
included in the packet so the processes
are still um widely varied by profession
um I'm just going to let director Kelly
if I missed anything that's really
crucial on that think we're pretty close
so if you had a specific profession in
mind I probably couldn't off the top of
my head get the rundown for you but I I
guess what I'm trying to get at is these
individual boards as you say differ
greatly do they give you a list of those
who were qualified and then you issue
the license no they set the standards in
Rule and they the standards are set to
be objective and then for those
applications we have a universal
application for the general information
that no matter who you are we need this
information and then boards can have
what is called an addendum or additional
profession specific questions other
requirements and basically the the the
clerk the licensed clerk looks and say
did they meet the criteria yes or no so
the boards are not evaluating the
individual applications unless there is
a question if it's unclear whether the
criteria was
meant does that does that
yeah um yeah I don't don't see too many
other questions um yeah I'd just like to
get more detail of um employees and
costs other costs right so more detailed
spreadsheet and then I guess we will let
you go all right thank you so much thank
you very much have a great afternoon all
right so um I guess our next one is
Liquor Commission at 3:15 so we'll
then
e
so I just wanted to explain I I handed
out a spreadsheet to you that you might
find useful um this is sort of the whole
ongoing budget at a glance okay so it
it's uh has fiscal year 2019 adjusted
authorized and fiscal year 2025 adjusted
authorized both for there's one column
for General and education funds and then
there's another column for total funds
so what's interesting about it is so
this is a sort of ongoing stuff it
doesn't have legislative specials that
show up in House Bill 2 but this is kind
of the basics of of what each agency
does and you can also see the the
percent change over that period of time
and by way of comparison if you if you
go to the back page you see that the
state totals are up by about a third 32%
33% here on the bottom line um over
those six years but if you look at
inflation over that period of time it's
about it's 25% according to the feds and
then we've had about a 4% population
growth so you know it's not that
outrageous but it you know it may be a
little over what you might expect just
from those two things right instead of
29% it's more like 32
33% so um but there's lots of individual
agencies that are either way up or way
down and so that's what this tells you
is is kind of where if we have to look
for savings where we might look for so
yes representative MS
um but I I think you know just looking
at it quickly I mean I I think you have
to be careful when you're doing the the
um comparisons year-over-year by agency
because I mean look at the first one
executive department it went from 40
million in 19 to 3.6 million in 25 so
yes I'm guessing that that's because
there was some money moved around some
other places you're right that that was
a reorganization so yes in some cases
like that you do have to understand that
some big thing moved out of this area
and into some other area but um if you
have questions about that LBA can can
answer them but for most of them it
that's not the case yeah all right uh
thank you uh for coming commissioner
please introduce
yourself thank you Mr chairman uh for
the record I'm Joseph mikica I'm the
chairman of the New Hampshire Liquor
Commission and with me is our CFO Tina
Demir uh I I think this this packet
comprehensively answers the questions
that you sent to us so we'll just get
started uh we'll give you a little
overview first that New Hampshire is one
of 17 controll jurisdictions in the
country uh and those are in the darker
color the three- tier system as it's
broken down um I won't bore you with the
details but it's a system that's been in
place since prohibition and it works
very well commissioner could I just ask
on the first one what are the polka dots
on Alaska Minnesota Etc yeah oh there's
usually a note on the bottom those are
the control counties that are within
those
States so we have the 17 jurisdictions
and then those counties within those
states of Minnesota South Dakota and
Alaska than you're
welcome so on page four we'll get to the
value of the three- tier system in the
biggest one the biggest value that we
feel of the three- tier system is the
product tracking which present prevents
the sale of Tainted or counterfeit
alcohol and that's something you don't
hear a lot of in the United States and
that's because of the three- tier system
you certainly don't hear a lot about it
in control
jurisdictions but as of 20 in 2024 1,200
people were affected by methanol tainted
alcohol and 400 people died and in the
past Last 5 Years
11,800 people have been affected and
4500 people have died and those are
worldwide figures again something you
don't see here in the United States very
much but it does happen uh unfortunately
in in the world itself in the country
so on page five competition just a quick
history in 2011 governor Patrick signed
a bill increasing the number of liquor
licenses that were allowed to be held
held by one person in the state for
years and years and years in
Massachusetts there been three licenses
so it never attracted any large
retailers into the state uh when he made
that change uh you saw Total Wine move
into the state and again just quickly
they're the nation's largest independent
Wine and Spirits retailer they're owned
by Two Brothers uh it's privately owned
they have 277 stores in 29 States and
11,000 employees and since since
2014 they have opened 12 stores in New
England uh for in Connecticut eight in
Massachusetts and that's very important
to us because 25% of our business comes
from Massachusetts 50% uh crossborder
sales here in the
State uh on page
six it's just uh some national and
Global figures impacting beverage
alcohol sales there's a number of things
that are uh we're seeing in the market
but the biggest thing is uh since
2023 there's been a 2% decline in
alcohol sales in the United States that
was the first decline in alcohol sales
in the United States in 31 years so
between 23 24 and 25 they're expecting
alcohol sales in the United States to be
down
5.9% and some of the reasons why we'll
get into in the next couple couple of
slides so National and Global factors in
impacting alcohol sales uh so for uh
number two for the first time in the
United States more Americans are using
marijuana on a daily basis or nearly
daily basis than alcohol there's a big
Neo prohibitionist mve in in the United
States and the potential upcoming
tariffs are something that we have to
take into consideration that could be a
mix book blessing because it could help
some of the US producers of wine and
spirits there happens to be a glut of
wine in
California uh
Tennessee uh Kentucky Alabama now we're
experiencing a glut of brown spirits and
brown Foreman the parent company of Jack
Daniels on Tuesday laid off 700
employees uh so again on page eight some
of the impact of cannabis Again The
Liquor Commission is not for or against
cannabis but it is something that
affects our business and we're seeing
that there's
355 licensed retailers in Massachusetts
218 licensed retailers in Maine and 79
licensed retailers in Vermont and the
corresponding revenues and taxes that go
we'll move to page 10 where we'll give
you a quick operational
numbers you'll see the exact numbers
that are given to those funds uh we are
govern governed under RSA
1763 and you'll see what governs the
commission and the responsibilities of
the commission
itself on page 11 a quick organizational
structure I'm sorry sure on this page I
don't see uh the amount transferred to
the general funds uh well when Tina goes
through the numbers you'll the end yeah
we'll go through everything there y
thank you Mr chairman for the question
on page 11 you'll see the organizational
structure of the commission and the
full-time uh positions represented in
the office of the commission the
division of enforcement the division of
administration and the division of
marketing those 285 positions in the
division of marketing also include all
the full-time employees that are in the
outlets as well
uh so the responsibilities of the office
of the commission the division of
enforcement the division of
administration and marketing are as
follows on page
12 on page 13 we've uh started we've uh
launched an NextGen project in last
April this is a a brand new
uh uh cloud-based system Microsoft
cloud-based system and this is some of
the things that we've done as as part of
the roll out of that project it's been
very successful as with any uh project
of that size uh we're replacing a 40y
old uh Hardware system and Software
System so this includes everything in
the back of the house and front of the
house for the Liquor Commission it's a
huge uh huge undertaking and it's
gone very well it has had a few things
and we've dealt with them as it's come
up but we're we're getting through it
and we feel that it's very successful as
do our licenses and the biggest piece of
it it was rolled out last April we ran
through a very busy summer season and
none of our customers knew that we were
on a new system so that's where we where
we live that's the most important thing
so on page
14 you'll see that we have nine
state-owned stores and the appro and the
square footage goes along with them 59
lease stores and the square footage that
goes along with that and we have now 37
Outlets that do curbside pickup and the
next piece we will move on to in the
near future is home
delivery on page 15 you have uh the
outlets the outlet changes renov
renovated 44 outlets in 35 communities
this is really all about building the
brand of the Liquor Commission which we
started to uh redevelop in around
2012 uh very successful uh nationally
recognized and we're hoping that our
consumers is enjoying what they see as
far as a selection and layout of our
stores marketing goals are on page 15
I'm sorry page
16 uh just we're trying to have
worldclass events we do a lot of
tastings we do a lot of Education we do
engagement with with celebrity owners
and people uh wine makers and Spirits
makers from around the country uh we're
trying to provide excellent service for
our for our customers which is our
primary goal and to be Innovative in all
areas uh this is very important for us
because we have that Total Wine to our
South and as I've said they're very
Innovative they're a very large company
not only do they do wine and spirits
they also do beer in their stores and uh
and tobacco as well a big big piece of
their business is things outside of the
alcohol world so we're trying to compete
with them and still remain uh
competitive in New England and so far we
seem to be doing a pretty good job of it
so on page
17 you'll see that our website in
Ecommerce
we have 125,000 visitors a month to our
website and as far as the curb store
curbside or in store pickup 3.2 million
in sales in 24 that's a
2.1% increase from 23 and we've done
12.2 million since its Inception in
2020 customers seem to like it they can
get online they can order their product
at home they can pay for it they can
stop at the store and pick it up on
their way to their summer home or skiing
or or wherever they're going to in the
state to
enjoy uh on page 18 just a couple of
quick brief figures on Instagram the
followers that we have over 10,000 on
Facebook over
162,000 and on Twitter or x a little
over 7,000 we send out seven target
targeted emails to our 180,000
recipients every month so we try not to
overburden uh we try to let people know
what's on sale particularly with one of
the new things that we're targeting is a
two for and a four for sale so it's a
multi- bottle sale very very very
successful so far and our suppliers and
Brokers love it as well because it's
moving boxes for
them on page 19 you'll see the Google
reviews 92% of our reviews are four and
five stars um we're very pleased with
that people that do come to the stores
are they're very vocal about what we're
doing and we're happy to see those
reviews on page 20 over the years since
2015 uh with the help of our broker
partners and suppliers they have do
donated product and we have benefited to
the tuna 4.3 million to these nonprofits
that are within the state that's not
profit that's leaving the Liquor
Commission to go to nonprofit
it's product that's brought in and then
auctioned off and or uh events that we
hold in order to help
nonprofits on page 21 you'll see the
enforcement Licensing Division so the
enforcement licensing and education is
the three-pronged
approach on page
22 you'll see the total number of
licenses active licenses that the Liquor
Commission and the enforcement division
specifically overseas at
6281 licenses and on the the right hand
side of the page the education and
awareness 2024 trainings uh total uh
persons trained is a little over 11,000
and public awareness through 59 events
that we hold Statewide is a little over
awareness and education just a few
things that we do uh fatal choices the
mobile the mobile Outreach buyers beware
uh contest posters and some forums and
the chief is usually on the Jack Heath
show every couple of weeks in order to
let lenes
consumers and public just to know what
we're doing as far as an educational
standpoint as far as licensing
education we license our own own folks
we license people in uh the restaurant
business so our Outreach is huge we see
you see here that we have manager
training seminars we do grocy education
T seminars and then a total alcohol
management as well as I've said liquor
and wine Outlet training for our stores
security training and fictitious ID
training uh just quickly on page 25 some
of the awards that the Liquor Commission
has re received in 26 over the few years
uh the most important one to us is from
market watch we've been one of the top
10 retailers for the last five years
from market watch which is basically uh
the wine and spirits magazine of the
country so that's been very impressive
for us and for this state to be able to
get those accolades uh those commanding
ACC accolades quite frankly so with that
being said I'll have Tina walk you
through the uh revenues and take it from
there thank
you good afternoon so on page 27 you
have the revenue transfers and the
transfer language which is the transfers
to
HHS uh being that we're self-funded our
projected revenue is dependent on the
budget that we're requesting starts off
with Row one our gross profit is down
slightly in 20
and projected to increase slightly in 26
and 27 with us adjusting um purchasing
and
discounting uh expense expense estimates
are increasing in 26 and 27 based on our
current projected spend with the net
revenue
flat uh the transfers are the two rsas
that are on the bottom of the page uh
the first one is the transfers regarding
uh RSA 17616 which is 5% of the prior
year gross profit to the alcohol abuse
and prevention fund and you'll see the
amounts range from 7.10 million and 24
up to 10.9 million in
27 then there's the transfer per RSA 126
AA colon 3 which is for granted
Advantage uh it was 7.2 million in 24
and is estimated by HHS for uh 25 at
13.3 million this is 6 million higher
than y
25 um this also includes an additional
1.1 million uh that we recently received
a letter um they have to quarterly um
ask for increases if there is a
shortfall in the fund and they say that
it's going to be a million to 2 million
this year that they're going to be short
so there's an additional money in there
for that so in 26 and 27 the amount is
12.6 and 13 million um for the total
transfers you'll see on row 7 to HHS uh
FY 24 was 17.9 million um to 23.4
million and then um in 26 and 27 is the
23.4 and the 23.9 million um then you
have the remaining liquor Revenue
transferred to the general fund in fy2
uh it's $8 million less because of that
additional 6 million that's going to
HHS um and then you have beer tax uh the
revenue transfer which is flat which
comes to the total transfer to the
10 so then on page 28 is our um 26 27
budget request we've also included the
24 actual and 25 adjusted authorized uh
after we met with governor aot and her
team we went back and re-evaluated our
budget for 26 and 27 and are proposing a
reduction each year by 3.3 million from
our original request where it's about
2.8% this aligns expense estimates with
our Revenue uh transfer estimates
currently and it's also important to
note that over the last 5 years we've
lapsed uh approximately 1 million to 6
million on average about 3.5 million we
lapse from our
budget so on page 29 you'll see um our
major expense categories that correspond
to the table on page 28 and then the
referencing line numbers um for easy
reference so the first one is salaries
and benefits they're 45% of our total
budget and they're increasing in 26 by
800,000 or
1.6% and 1.5 million or 2.9% in 27 but
we are cutting 900,000 each year by uh
unfund seven positions that we currently
have on hold and we've reduced overtime
part-time and Associated
benefits number two is uh current
expense in 26 it's decreasing 7.4% or
370,000 in 27 it's level funded and
we're cutting a 100,000 in each
year then there's rents and leases the
funding um is for our current rent
obligations and potential relocations
and we're going to cut this line by
00,000 each year utilities is number
four FY 26 is down
500,000 uh or 16.6% and then we're level
funding in 27 and cutting about 26,000
each year in that
line number five contracts for
operational Services uh this includes
all of our contracts for store
maintenance uh such as you know
electrical HVAC security systems uh
doors uh and our nextg our new nextg
system um this funding is based on our
current contracts and our projected
needs and we're cutting that line by
about 350,000 each
year number six technology hardware and
software FY 26 is decreasing 1.6 million
or 61% and this is from changes in our
in needs we did move some funding from
the supporting of our system from this
line to our contracts line and the
remaining funding is for for
subscriptions and the cloud-based
Services based on our current
agreements number seven doit funding for
annual software requirements uh
replacing equipment such as laptops and
handheld devices uh we're cutting this
line 1.4 million each year and this was
done in collaboration with
doit we have equipment this includes um
shelving checkout counters cameras cars
uh and we're cutting this line by
400,000 each
year number nine is travel FY 26 the
increas is to support the current trend
for maintaining State vehicles and uh
supports shifting of staff from One
retail location to another to pay travel
and for any store
moves number 10 other expenses FY 26 is
decreasing in debt Services based on the
current Bond schedule and estimates for
new bonds and workers comp is based
decreasing based on on uh historical
Trend and then there's an increase in
indirect cost and this is based on the
estimates provided by Das and then FY 27
is level funded one thing you will note
is my numbering on here is a little off
um number grants is number 12 and
they're increasing based on uh the
available funding from FDA for tobacco
compliance and then uh it should be
number 13 which is the transfer to other
funds so for transparency purposes and
to make it easier uh we put in the
item so on page 30 and 31 um these are
the annual breakdown by class and
accounting unit the breakdown is
consistent for both years in both class
and accounting unit so in FY 26 our
current proposed budget is 3.3 million
or 2.8% less than
fy2 and the original um 26 requests
our funding source is primarily liquor
funds with less than a million from
federal and other funds and those are
our grants so by class the largest
categories are salaries and benefits at
45% and then the transfer to HHS at 20%
and then rent with 10% and then you can
see by accounting unit store operations
budget so on the next Pages uh you'll
see we provided a summary by division as
listed in the budget book um with page
references for the book uh there's a pie
chart that shows the breakdown by the
class category and an explanation for
changes um and these numbers are based
on the proposed Cuts so starting with
the office of the commission overseeing
all operations of the commission with
the primary goal to increase sales and
maximize profits while operating in a
cost effective and efficient manner
you'll see that FY 26 it's decreasing
slightly by 50,000 or 2.8% and then 27
is level funded uh the main reason for
the decrease in 26 is we moved one
position from here to the division of
administration and then there were some
increases in indirect cost for the
change in how it's allocated by
divisions and a decrease in contracts
and current
expense so on page 33 is the division of
enforcement uh this includes enforcement
licensing and education and grants uh
the division is responsible for
enforcing alcoholic beverage laws
enforcing youth access to tobacco and
providing licensing education and
support for over the 6100 lenses or
6200 um so the FY 26 is increasing 12%
or 579,000 and fy2 7 is increasing 2.7%
or
143,000 the reason for the increase in
26 is we moved one full-time position
and five part-time positions to create a
new loss prevention program to help with
um thefts in the stores and Public
Safety with no trespass orders and
they've had great success with the
program um the liquor store they visited
79% of the liquor stores the arrest up
91% uh so operations they are increasing
37,000 and this is for fuel and repair
for their state cars and 27 is um
increasing slightly um for salaries and
steps and benefit
increases so on page 34 is the division
of administration this is includes uh
Finance HR audit inventory control and
legal and as part of a restructuring we
moved our real estate and maintenance
department along with um we created a
department for the new system support so
there was a total of 12 positions moved
from other divisions into this
division so FY 26 there's a decrease um
slate decrease and FY 27 is an increase
increase of 2.5 or 270,000 so what
you'll see here is salaries and benefits
increased 1.9 million for those 12
positions for all of those different
locations but the offset is the decrease
in doit by the 1.8 million so it netted
out and then there's slight increase in
26 I mean slight decrease in 26 um for
the reallocation of indirect costs and
then there's a slight increase because
we had to move the rent expense for for
the maintenance department into this and
funded then there's the division of
marketing and Merchandising this
includes marketing merchandising uh
advertising retail store outlets and the
headquarters Warehouse the division
oversees the buying marketing selling
and distributing of product through all
channels to promote sales and maximize
profits
in FY 26 the decrease is 2.5% or 2.5
million this decrease is primarily from
moving positions and the positions move
to the other Division and then unfund
those uh other seven positions and then
FY 27 the increas is primarily from
salary step and benefit and then
increases in retire health benefits and
then you'll see under the operations
there's 's um a decrease in the debt and
the
technology um in utilities and then an
increase in contracts rents and indirect
costs and then on page 36 workers comp
and unemployment comp uh workers comp is
decreasing 71% or
87,000 and this number was provided by
risk management and is based on the
historical Trend so it's good that
workers comp costs have been going down
and then un unemployment comp is level
funded and then the final page um to
answer the questions that were sent by
the chairman um we have no general fund
Appropriations uh this page shows the
list of new positions that we've had in
the last 5 years they were all
established in 24 and they are 100%
liquor funded and on the bottom you'll
see the positions that we are currently
holding and are proposing to unfund and
then we did not receive any oper funds
so we haven't had to adjust any funding
for
that and we'll be happy to answer any
questions on this last page 37 are these
numbers include benefits or these yes
they include benefits salary and
benefits
great um and then the other question I
had was um page 27
yes uh transfer to
gcp um granted Advantage Healthcare
program so there's a big jump from 24 to
is that is to offset funding that
um I don't I don't there something to
ask HHS yes something to ask HHS because
the numbers are provided by them great
all right other members have questions
representative rang then representative
Lee thank you Mr chairman um and thank
you for your presentation I have a
couple questions
um if someone is buying wine from out of
state let's say a wine club and it's
being delivered into New Hampshire how
does that tax work the manufacturer or
the the dist the out of state
distributor pays New Hampshire the tax
on that part of the direct shipping it's
part of Direct ship the consumer would
pay the tax on that oh okay and um I
know there 's been an increase in THC
beverage sales um same thing model
somebody buys it from out of state it
gets delivered in New Hampshire are
those also taxed those are those are
done through the beer wholesalers it's
not something that we carry so any THC
products are are are done to a beer
wholesaler okay so are they are they
subject to New Hampshire
tax I can check for you okay I don't
know I would imagine that it would be
part of what they would have to report
as their sales sales beer tax and their
tax so the tax any of the products that
they sell would go through uh would go
through their their total sales which is
tax by gallon and that's the tax that we
collect 30 30 cents okay so even though
cannabis isn't legalized in New
Hampshire um people can purchase them
from and have them delivered into New
Hampshire um without
no not none of the Cannabis products are
legal in New Hampshire so they're not
you're seeing some hemp products perhaps
okay these are just like they're called
THC and they sell them in um the
different strengths so I don't know if
the THC is derived from Cannabis or not
maybe it is derived from something
another plant my my guess is that it
would be a hemp product canab okay and
then um another question there's a huge
Ray area here oh okay huge you know
because you know where you you're
talking about the competition from
Cannabis that might I was just looking
trying to find
Opportunities um when we talk about the
competition of cannabis it's not it's
not necessarily in the beverage Market
that we're speaking of okay we're we're
recognizing and the country is
recognizing when people are uh when
people are spending dollars on cannabis
uh in the three states around us let's
say between
Massachusetts uh Maine and Vermont we're
talking about $3 billion do in cannabis
sales a year so U everyone only has so
much Expendable income and it's 44% of
the people today are using cannabis over
alcohol it was 33% last year so that
we're we're seeing Nationwide that
decline in alcohol for a number of re
reasons the health
benefits the presumed health benefits
you've got the uh Surgeon General saying
that any amount of alcohol is no good
for you and could potentially cause
cancer you have the Baby Boomers aging
out of the market which is a huge piece
of people that have bought alcohol for
years they grew up with that group of
people they covered it Millennials
buying patterns are different so they
don't buy in cupboard they buy for today
so instead of coming in and taking the
deal on the 12 bottles of wine at 15%
off they'll come in and buy one bottle
and it's just a it's a complete
different mindset so we're adjusting for
that but losing that huge segment of the
market on top of the Cannabis on top of
the health benefits is kind of The
Perfect Storm for alcohol Nationwide
thus the 5.9% decline in 3 years
and the first decline in 30 years in
2023 at
2.9% so this is this is not a New
Hampshire phenomenon this is this is
around the country we're seeing this we
just happen to be surrounded by by one
of the issues and are dealing with the
other issues the national issues uh of
the Surgeon General making comments
about alcohol and People's Health trends
and the Baby Boomers aging out of the
market so with those exponential dollars
not being spent in alcohol we're seeing
this Nationwide represent leishman oh
you can come back to me I have one more
I don't mind she wants to ask all right
well thank you um I think you also
mentioned this but also the growth in
non-alcoholic spirits and I was I saw a
segment on television I think it was
last week about stores that are selling
this
is that an opportunity for the Liquor
Commission to add to its offering
non-alcoholic wine or Spirits things
like that we we do we've we've run we
have a number of non-alcoholic products
in our stores we have non-alcoholic
Spirits we have non-alcoholic wine and
low alcohol wine what we're tending to
see in the market is not one segment of
things the mocktail is the biggest piece
and we run a mocktail month every month
where we partner with our business
partners our lies around the state but
even I watched a program the other night
from New York a food program and it's a
national nationally syndicated program
and everything they did every cocktail
they made was a mocktail so we're
carrying all those things in our stores
for people to make those mocktails we
have recipe guides for them they're on
our website there so we recognize that
it's a part of the market that's growing
it just happens to be a very small part
of the market but as it grows it will it
could be more substantial okay thank you
you're welcome thank you let me ask a
question directly related to that is our
profit margin on a mocktail much less
than um on alcohol because we don't have
any special advantage over a grocery
store or some other thing well most of
the items that are used to make a
mocktail are non-alcoholic so this the
few items that we have in our stores
we're making we're making our markup on
but the real winner of this is the
lenses because you're seeing they're
they're their bartenders are creative
the people that work for them are
creative as they should be I was in the
business for 30 years I would want my my
folks to be doing that and they're
selling a non-alcoholic cocktail or a
mocktail for as much or more in some
cases than they are for a gin and tonic
let's say and their cost is widely
reduced because there's no alcohol in
the drink but my point was they don't
have to buy the the contents from you no
they could go to Market Basket or go
anywhere absolutely there's no specific
products that we carry to make mocktails
that aren't available in Market baskets
or at the corner store quite frankly
right all right representative
Lee thank you Mr
chairman so looking at uh chairman
Maguire's
uh chart here if you will uh it shows
the same I guess in my
opinion uh Trend over the last few years
of increase expenses if these numbers
are correct which I sure they are it's
like 55% increase between 19 and 25
so I went back and looked and our
expenses back in 2014 were $48 million
and now we're running you know well over
well 120,000 I $120 million for expenses
what's the real driving force here is IT
personnel
Insurance uh the concern I also have is
the debt service line uh we are carrying
a lot of debt and I see that you've got
two stores planned for uh 95 north and
south is are those going to be paid for
with debts or how is that going to I I'm
sorry I threw a couple of questions in
here Mr chairman but so well the first
thing is to back off the 20 million for
the transfer to HHS there's that's new
expense then um in 24 and 25 the pay
raise increase equated to $4 million um
each year um the debt service we have um
an RSA or there's statue out there for
when we sell the Hampton properties that
the funding that we receive from selling
that land will go towards paying down
our debt so the goal is is that our debt
would be substantially reduced and
either the building of the stores will
be part of that agreement or it we do
have a capital appropriation for about
$15 million to build
stores further question Mr chairman so
where is that 15 million going to come
from to build those two stores we have a
capital appropriation appropriation and
that's all liquor funds entirely liquor
okay so I guess the um the other
question I have if you could provide us
with the total revenues for the last
several years so we can compare that
with expenses and what we're getting
back I know it's in the $700 million
range plus or minus I guess more plus
but I'm just curious on the trend over
the last you know five six seven years
on revenues coming in with expenses plus
what we're getting back and the chairman
and I um I think share a concern of the
transfer um without any budget for the
drug and alcohol fund and said are you
aware do they prepare any sort of budget
are you aware of that or are you just
send them the money as required by the
statute they send us a letter requesting
the money in send it to them as required
by the statute yeah so the numbers I I
put in here were provided by HHS is the
estimated funding that they need and
you're not aware that there's a budget
they present anywhere no so okay thank
you yeah I think that's HHS but in in
the past that has sometimes been um
suspended um let me ask a big picture
kind of question compared to Total Wine
what's the source of of any
um any lower costs for us by comparison
to them I mean presumably they pay
federal income tax we don't things like
that are there other kinds of taxes that
they owe that that we don't I mean is
there some source of of our profits over
them I'm not sure I call Total Wine
Total Wine is your big competitor in
Massachusetts right but that's a private
company correct right so they have to
pay federal income tax for example on
their profits we don't right so that's
one source of of higher profits for us
by comparison but maybe their volumes
are much higher than ours and therefore
they get a better price from Jack
Daniels than we do or something like you
know so so I'm trying to say how do we
compare with them in terms
of what's the main source of our low
prices well competitive buying is the
main source of our low prices so we work
with our suppliers and we work them hard
because we've been in business for a
long time we have great relationships
Total Wine does about6 billion dollar
this year in sales the biggest piece of
what they do that we don't do is they're
a private labeler so 70% of the product
that's on their sh
are products that they own and label so
they may
have they knock off Brands all the time
and I could walk you through dozens of
them that that they do but what they do
is they Source directly from let's say
chardonay from from California and
they'll do six to 12 to 15 labels of
chardonay from California in a bottle so
they're bulk they're bulk buying they're
diversifying in their labels whether it
be in Bourbon uh vodka gin rum or wine
so their profit level on those items is
probably somewhere in the 45% range they
are a huge loss leader so they'll market
against our prices but when consumers
get there they don't have the quantity
of pro of of product that we're looking
for that they're looking for that our
consumers are looking for so that's the
advantage that New Hampshire has we work
on about a
28% GP and about a 21 20 to 21% net
profit which is extremely good for any
business but even in the alcohol
business but Total Wine makes their
money on private labeling they'll lose
money on
Tios but they'll make it up on Tower
which is their Tito's knockoff so sell
it for three or four dollar a bottle
less it's made in
Texas I see there you go do does um is
there some other kind of federal tax on
liquor does the federal government tax
liquor x dollar per gallon or something
like that that they pay and we don't or
no no any of that any of that tax from a
federal standpoint is paid at the
manufacturing and Distilling level I see
so we both pay it then we well
indirectly we pay it through our through
the cost of what we buy yes gotcha okay
thank you other questions representative
evil not quite as
complicated um the wine that you buy in
grocery stores do the stores here buy it
from you or they just pay how does that
work they buy it from us we sell we sell
it to them
so we're the wholesaler in that respect
and we're the retailer in what we do we
pass along as good a pricing as we
possibly can to them and we give them
between 15 and 40 to 50 specials a month
where we will reduce our profit on them
so they can make a little bit more money
in their stores but everything that they
buy is bought through us and it used to
be I thought that they couldn't unell
you is that still the case well in
some I don't believe that there's any
law or rule that says that they can't
undersell us they typically don't
because the convenience factor is really
what they're they're they're buying now
they markup in some items that we would
that we deal back to them that we give
them a good deal on so they'll buy in
heavy on those products keep the retail
at their normal retail and make the
additional markup they're not
necessarily passing it along to the
consumer and you know as business people
we know in respect they do what they
have to do but they're they're clearly
dealing on convenience if you're at the
store and you're you're there and your
your product that you normally buy is in
front of you and it's two or three doll
more than what we would charge if you're
going to buy a bottle there you're going
to buy a bottle there is that much of
your sales to to other private to like
Market Basket and it's a big piece of
what we do I I we can tell you the exact
number I don't have it here but Tina
probably does in her book but it's a
it's a large piece of what we do okay
and then my other question is the um cut
that you have 1.4 million per year in
collaboration with do that those are
pretty big numbers I mean what what does
that actually reflect and will that harm
you operationally no we've been working
with doit for a while on these Cuts we
actually as Tina said we went during the
during the project of NextGen we we had
we got to a a piece in the project
where because of the Microsoft based
product no one at doit was as familiar
with the product as Microsoft itself so
what we
did they Dennis came to me and said this
is not something that we can support we
don't have the people to support this so
you're need you're going to need to go
outside to get people to support this
Microsoft based product so we stood up
uh an an entity within the commission
and Tina went through that piece and now
those folks within the Liquor Commission
are doing it and we dealt back those
positions from doit so it's it was a
wash more or less but they basically
didn't have the expertise
that we went out for bid we went out for
an RFP and got a bidder to do part of it
and then we are doing part of it inhouse
we took some of those folks over the the
help Des people specifically we took
them we were funding them at doit we
move them to the commission and fund
them there so and just to answer your
question so on premise sales are 95
million or 12% of our business and off-
premise was about 119 or 15.6% of our
business in FY
24 and the retail outlets did 547
million so they're they're a big piece
of what we do and good partners and we
work with them closely to make sure that
you know they're profitable in what we
do because we recognize that our
consumers win regardless of where they
buy and if it's convenient for them to
buy while they're grocery shopping we
completely understand that cuz I always
feel guilty if I buy something at a
grocery
store did I see representative ms's hand
no okay anyone else let me uh yeah let
me ask um you mentioned you talked about
licensing is all of your licensing of
organizations or companies and not of
individuals uh well depending on how the
businesses are set up we license
uh you know we license people all over
the country a lot of those licenses are
Direct ship licenses so people in
California that want to send wine to the
state and pay that tax the John Hunt tax
as it's known uh that that those people
are licensed and a lot of it's kind of a
neat program kind of a neat setup
because a lot of that wine specifically
wine wouldn't be available to Consumers
because a lot of those small Niche
Vineyards 1 2 3 acres that that wine
never leaves the vineyard so that we
allow direct ship into the state and
that being that we're in a computer age
our consumers can go to those websites
buy that wine and have it shipped in so
it is we're one of 13 states that allows
that with wine and we're one of eight
states that allows spirits to be shipped
in so we're we're pretty far ahead of
the game just where I was thinking about
here was that we just had oplc in and
and the question was came to my mind if
any of your licensing would be more more
appropriately or more easily done by
oplc it doesn't sound like it because
they don't license they only license
individuals who are doing some you know
plumbers or whatever but not yeah the
the only place we cross pass is if we
you know they license a barber shop and
the barber shop wants a liquor license
so that's where you know some things
would cross paths but it's two separate
licenses two separate things
time all right representative Lehman did
you have a
question okay and do them on the side
okay all right I guess we can stop early
a little bit all right very good we'll
see you all next Wednesday thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee thank
you very much yeah yeah yeah right we
have the full committee tomorrow at 10:
right and I'm the chairman of that
because Ken's off um his um grandson is
getting a Green Beret so he's he's uh
ceremony
e